UNKNOWN: it's our training art yeah all right everyone good all right why are we rolling dice
Roma: why are we running guys because i'm also wondering why we're rolling names
UNKNOWN: but this is why we're rolling guys i'm just testing okay cool i'm deleting everything
Roma: let's go hey just wait jesus christ yeah training art training art training more
UNKNOWN: what are you giving me one second slaughter and mayhem it's never a good thing when we
Bob: fight yeah and i verify what the was that
Roma: was that a burp or was that you
UNKNOWN: yes something growling
UNKNOWN: what the what what is kate doing why is he going
UNKNOWN: in peace form how do i get him to change that
Roma: there's something at the top probably is
UNKNOWN: oh roma hears that noise he's definitely gonna go yeti
Roma: yeah everybody just starts transforming
UNKNOWN: does jack have a transformation wait who transformed who did what what's happening well
Jack: uh uh kate said tiger no he didn't
Bob: how huh like that huh what kate turned into a tiger and roma turned into a yeti nothing much
UNKNOWN: not yet not yet i just said if he heard that noise he would go yeti
Kakashi: stop sorry wait where where was the sound coming from i don't understand
UNKNOWN: hey what's up okay so it's for fun
Roma: can we move on now we can move on we're waiting okay
UNKNOWN: we should have moved on already we're gonna move on geez give him a break guys
UNKNOWN: he's the one that said can we move on yeah so we're moving we are moving
UNKNOWN: okay um let me get the music going
Roma: that's safe
SPEAKER_08: so what do you tell us the person who asked you to do this uh
Jack: something else
UNKNOWN: was i being a priest and it's no recommend so it's un winding
Kakashi: so there's like a ten minute sequence in the end of the video
Kakashi: you picked a topic related to you if you wanted to happen so if i picked a topic related to you
Kakashi: the east side as you were told to go to that part of the island and you will notice the
UNKNOWN: waterfall that was mentioned uh as you arrive toward the entrance of the waterfall
UNKNOWN: uh where is everyone right now okay wait you're in the kitchen
Jack: yeah somewhere around there probably cleaning the bit of blood of my coat
UNKNOWN: okay uh bob where are you probably sleeping in his room
Kakashi: okay
Roma: he said cry kate is at the helm baptiste where are you
Baptiste: i'm with
Kakashi: blue nearby kate okay uh and uh at this point you would be approached by
Kakashi: linus and zim at the same time they look at each other they look at you and they go uh
Kakashi: at least we've been talking and i think it's best that we separate for now
Kakashi: and you can meet up with mira and we can take the spare boat
Kakashi: and we can take the spare boat
Kakashi: that you have maybe get on the island get some information and try to help out a little bit
UNKNOWN: you know the maul families are currently at maul
SPEAKER_07: oh don't worry they do not know that we are affiliated with you and we too have been
SPEAKER_08: pretty used to living in the dark not getting the
Kakashi: i think it's best for everyone that
UNKNOWN: mia does not see me or zim with you in all honesty i am kind of scared of her
UNKNOWN: i don't blame you
Kakashi: he puts his show his hand on your shoulder and he just genuinely just looks at you in your eyes
UNKNOWN: and says try not to die melsis
Kakashi: he turns around and starts walking uh zim looks at you and she goes well i suppose this is it huh
Baptiste: at least for a while we're going to see each other soon don't make it weird i'm not i'm not
SPEAKER_08: making it weird you're making it weird she just turns around and just leaves
UNKNOWN: uh
SPEAKER_04: i know you'll miss me
UNKNOWN: yeah right
Kakashi: uh
Kakashi: linus at this point will start uh drawing down the boat as the boat get off and just wave you
Kakashi: goodbye as they start uh rowing toward a small dock on the side of the island that you can spot
Kakashi: from here um as you start to get closer and closer to the island you'll see that the boat is
Kakashi: closer to the waterfall the splashes of the waterfall start to sound louder and louder
Kakashi: as you start getting near and near uh the water rushes down on the ship and uh the mast needs to
Kakashi: be closed to get through this place um because like they will get wet and they will all clump
Kakashi: together so uh kate will ask anyone who can help to close up the
UNKNOWN: mast i'll sit lou down and go to close the mass
UNKNOWN: then after that i'm yelling for everybody to gather on
Bob: yeah bubbles crying himself to sleep but now he's there okay crying for what
UNKNOWN: he's dead no what's new he's alive he's very much has long what what is even death right
SPEAKER_08: his eliminate
SPEAKER_08: right
SPEAKER_08: breathing are you breathing you're fucking alive stop crying uh can you see me like no i'm not
SPEAKER_04: breathing excuse me waterfalls don't have to breathe remember okay can you see me do your eyes
Kakashi: work no okay as everyone uh closes up the mast uh kate just like reels the ship into the waterfall
UNKNOWN: as you pass through and i'll be sending you to uh as you start uh going deeper and deeper in this
Kakashi: cave you can kind of see because of the light shimmering from behind through the waterfall you
Kakashi: can kind of see the initial um cave but as you start to get deeper and deeper in the cave the
Kakashi: lights start to dim as you kind of notice the surroundings a little bit more
Kakashi: the cave is pretty large and has like a large water body at the center and maybe at the there
Kakashi: is some somewhere back uh on the other side of the cave where you can uh get off the ship but
Kakashi: you can't see that right now uh on the uh sides of the cave you do see like big indents uh of
Kakashi: something hitting the cave walls from time to time
Kakashi: uh as you start to get deeper and deeper in the cave you can kind of see the lights start to dim
UNKNOWN: as you start to get deeper and deeper into the cave you in
Kakashi: yep um you light up some of the lanterns on the ship uh with some light you can see around you
Kakashi: uh can everyone give me a perception check sure even though i'm in the kitchen
Kakashi: no you don't have to then if you're still in the kitchen
Kakashi: whoever's on deck can give me a perception check uh can somebody else move and see if
Bob: lou moves with them because every time i try to move lou is just getting away
UNKNOWN: uh i think you have him selected that's why hands off my dog
UNKNOWN: what the hell uh maybe just reload okay uh okay no one else on the deck except for kate i'll do uh
SPEAKER_08: nice perception check
SPEAKER_08: oh my god he's too worried about chasing lou
SPEAKER_08: his eyes don't work actually
Kakashi: lou uh was in your arms for a bit as he just jumps off and runs into like a small uh
Kakashi: like opening in one of like the crates so
Kakashi: whatever he senses something getting closer and you start to hear it too as it gets closer and
Kakashi: closer you hear some splashing around uh off the water it's like moving at the speed of like
Kakashi: some something's like thrashing into the water and heading towards you with great speed uh as
Kakashi: you start to see like this figure roaming around in the water circling the ship
Kakashi: uh the the figure is like currently submerged in the water so you just see a shadow mostly
Kakashi: and as it circles around he it whatever it is it starts to get up and you can see
Kakashi: out of the water it's
Kakashi: a sea beast in the shape of kind of like an armadillo and uh porcupine mix as it starts to
Kakashi: thrash onto the ship uh are you uh are you located where you are located baptiste or
Kakashi: are you somewhere else because i want to make sure okay uh it will try to attack you
UNKNOWN: because it just sees you as food this is inside the waterfall
Baptiste: there's inside the waterfall yeah oh no better not be what i think it is oh
Baptiste: this better not be what i think it is
Jack: i think it is what you think it is
Jack: yeah 25 oh no okay um it is going to hit you
UNKNOWN: um and uh
Kakashi: as it's trying to like jump out of the water and like uh bite at you it stops midway roma you uh can
Roma: you make me a concept 19 uh 19 roma you start to hear like this high pitch sound it's starting to
Kakashi: like cause a headache in your head and it seems to be originating from outside
Roma: oh so i'm going i'm gonna go yeah and
Kakashi: as you start getting closer and closer the sound will get uh louder and louder uh you
Kakashi: get on like uh out of the kitchen and you just see like baptiste surrounded by this
Kakashi: uh large sea beast uh the sea beast like puts his head right alongside you and it opens his mouth
Kakashi: and you see like a big green blob of something just lays flat in front of you
UNKNOWN: what do you want to do next
Kakashi: in front of me
Kakashi: no no in front of baptiste
Kakashi: the sound has stopped roma at this point
SPEAKER_04: there's just a green blob in front of you
Kakashi: yeah just a green slimy subs like big substance like a human-shaped substance in front of you
SPEAKER_04: what is this
SPEAKER_08: are you approaching
Kakashi: so you cut off what did you say
Baptiste: i said i'll approach it
Kakashi: okay uh as you approach it you're going to see like a green blob in front of you
Kakashi: and as you approach the the thing whatever it is starts to move
Kakashi: and you can see kind of like an eye inside of it as uh it locks in as like the um eye contact as
Kakashi: soon as the eye contact happens the thing kind of crawls onto like on all its four
UNKNOWN: legs or whatever and it starts crawling up to you what are you doing baptiste was take a step back
Baptiste: at first and he'll just
Baptiste: and still be like
Roma: does anyone have a
Roma: table
UNKNOWN: what
UNKNOWN: does anyone have a towel
SPEAKER_07: uh i mean probably someone can grab a towel and throw baptiste
Bob: not on me
Bob: red
Bob: you're draped in a robe
SPEAKER_09: he's not going to take off his clothes
SPEAKER_09: what do you mean
Kakashi: whatever that object is is starting to get close are you saying i'm gonna take off his clothes
Baptiste: are you stepping back no i'm gonna let it get closer okay be on guard it's getting closer and
Kakashi: closer and it's trying it's now at this point trying to like grab your uh legs and it's going
Kakashi: to grab your legs it's not small it's like a human size like maybe uh six six two yeah it's going to
Kakashi: grab your legs as it like kind of like uh uses your body weight as the strength to try to get up
Kakashi: and it's crawling back onto your like robe and like start trying to get up to your like eye level
Kakashi: as the eye becomes clearer and clearer as the goop starts to flow down you can see it's
Kakashi: trey your best buddy trey
SPEAKER_08: uh he he starts to like sniffle and just like
SPEAKER_08: clean himself on you and he goes oh i'm so glad to see you buddy
UNKNOWN: wait why are you it's oh my god it's okay he'll like pat his head
Kakashi: oh you're so nice to me now can you ask julie to leave me alone and he like points back at the
Kakashi: monster and inside of it you see like the monster like rolls out its tongue and you see julie like
Kakashi: kind of like walking uh like one leg in front of another waving her arm side by side as she jumps
Kakashi: down and she goes hey you're here all right where's my where's my present where is it it's
Kakashi: She, like, runs around.
Kakashi: Where's the fucking token for Julie, man?
Kakashi: Oh, there we go.
Jack: Did we come to the same conclusion that that was the pets that we all scalded?
Jack: Yeah.
Kakashi: Yeah, okay.
Kakashi: She, like, kind of, like, runs around the deck and is, like, trying to look for what you brought her.
Kakashi: And she runs back to you and goes, where is it?
UNKNOWN: We had a deal.
UNKNOWN: What?
SPEAKER_04: Did you let Trey rest?
Kakashi: He was resting inside Crunch.
Kakashi: Right?
Kakashi: Hi, Trey.
Kakashi: Trey kind of, like, scarily, like, hides behind you.
Kakashi: She goes, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Kakashi: I was resting for sure.
UNKNOWN: See?
Kakashi: Now, where's my present?
Kakashi: Oh, is that him?
UNKNOWN: She runs up to Roma.
Kakashi: And he goes, hey, are you my new pet?
Roma: I'm going to give her the quick, like, Heisman stiff arm.
Roma: Be like, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa.
Roma: Who the hell are you?
Kakashi: Okay, she is going to raise her arm and kind of pat your head.
Kakashi: What are you doing?
Roma: Pat my head?
UNKNOWN: Yeah.
Roma: How tall is she?
Kakashi: She's, like, four, four three.
Jack: She got sliced?
Kakashi: Yeah, she just has her hand up.
Kakashi: She's not, like, actually patting.
Kakashi: She just hands her hands up.
Kakashi: She's expecting you to, like, come down to her height.
Roma: Oh, come, come.
Kakashi: It's fine.
Kakashi: Just let me pat your head.
Kakashi: Oh, he can talk, too.
Kakashi: That's really good.
Roma: He can talk, too.
Roma: Who are you?
Kakashi: I'm Julie.
Kakashi: Who are you?
Roma: Oh, Baptiste didn't tell you.
Kakashi: I'm the mascot for the Braveheart Pirates.
UNKNOWN: Yes.
Kakashi: Now, come here.
Baptiste: You see what I deal with, Trey?
SPEAKER_08: Oh, you don't know half of what I deal with.
SPEAKER_08: Okay, just fucking tell him.
Baptiste: I'll start patting his head again.
Roma: You're going to pat Trey's head.
Roma: Hmm.
UNKNOWN: Hey.
Baptiste: It's the worst crew, Roma.
Roma: Roma's going to see that and try to pat the little girl's head.
Kakashi: As you try to, like, get close to her, can you make me a wisdom save?
SPEAKER_04: Oh, her pet is about to eat you.
UNKNOWN: Okay.
Kakashi: As you try to, like, get close to her, you don't even see as the monster is going to
Kakashi: eat you.
Kakashi: The monster just, like, swims around and just, like, puts, like, its claws right in front
Kakashi: of you.
Kakashi: Oh, it's fine.
Kakashi: Crunch.
Kakashi: They're friends.
Kakashi: We don't hurt our friends.
Kakashi: It's your new buddy, Roma.
UNKNOWN: All right.
UNKNOWN: Okay.
SPEAKER_08: Bob is just running away.
Kakashi: As Julie is, like, still, like, kind of having her hand, like, up in the air.
Kakashi: She's still expecting you to, like, bow down and, like, let her pet you.
Baptiste: Let her do it, Roma.
UNKNOWN: That's a lose for her.
UNKNOWN: You're worse.
SPEAKER_13: I'm what?
SPEAKER_13: You're worse.
UNKNOWN: All right.
Kakashi: At this point, she just kind of gets tired and runs back to you.
Kakashi: And she goes, you lied to me.
Kakashi: You didn't bring me friends.
SPEAKER_04: I said they might not like you.
UNKNOWN: No.
Kakashi: Everyone likes me.
SPEAKER_04: You said your current pet doesn't like you right now because you can't feed it.
UNKNOWN: No.
Kakashi: Crunch likes me.
Kakashi: He's just a little sad that he can't have more food.
Kakashi: Do you have food on your ship?
Baptiste: I'm going to point back to Roma.
Jack: You go, Roma's ears, like, perk up.
Jack: Be like, yes.
Jack: That's the foods.
Kakashi: Oh, does he have food?
Kakashi: Okay.
UNKNOWN: She, like, runs back to Roma.
Kakashi: No.
Kakashi: Bad Baptiste.
Kakashi: We don't eat friends.
Kakashi: That's what Mira says anyway.
UNKNOWN: I know.
UNKNOWN: Okay.
Kakashi: She, like, runs up to you and she just, like, politely asks for food.
Roma: What would you like, madam?
Roma: I'll make it for you.
Kakashi: Um.
Kakashi: Crunch eats a lot of fishes and meat and I don't know.
Kakashi: He eats a lot.
UNKNOWN: Well, I'll give him something.
UNKNOWN: Okay.
Kakashi: Just be careful.
Kakashi: If it's not enough, he's going to eat you.
UNKNOWN: All right.
Kakashi: Bye-bye.
Kakashi: Okay.
UNKNOWN: All right.
Kakashi: Roma, you go back in.
Kakashi: You whip up something.
Kakashi: Julie is, like, running around and just, like.
Kakashi: Trying to, like, look for anything else interesting on the ship.
Kakashi: Well, Trey is, at this point, pretty cleaned up.
Kakashi: Like, the slime has, like, gotten off of his body.
Kakashi: And he's, like, trying to, like.
Kakashi: He takes off, like, his jacket that he was wearing.
Kakashi: And he, like, twists it to, like, get the slime off completely.
Kakashi: And he just, like, ties it around his waist.
Kakashi: There he goes.
Kakashi: Well.
Kakashi: Um.
Kakashi: Okay.
Kakashi: So.
Kakashi: You're here.
Kakashi: How well do you think you're prepared for what's coming?
SPEAKER_04: You can never be prepared for Mira.
Kakashi: I suppose that's true.
Kakashi: Well, here she comes.
Kakashi: He just runs away.
Kakashi: And you start to hear, like, this rumbling in the cave.
Kakashi: and you feel that this like immense pressure even higher than what you were feeling during when the
Kakashi: sea beast was like uh swimming around arrive from the skies uh can everyone give me another
UNKNOWN: perception on the deck whoever is on the deck uh wind starts to like uh flow very fast towards
Kakashi: the uh end of the cavern in the sky as like the winds like start to twirl around and after a few
Kakashi: seconds it starts to pull you with the force uh and uh can everyone make a deck save oh come on
Kakashi: all right bob you just get swept off your feet as you start to like just fly
Kakashi: off the water
Kakashi: uh off the ship uh you can try to grab on to like the any of the pillars or the side of the ship
Kakashi: whatever uh give me a strength check for that uh baptiste you're fine roma you're inside so you're
Kakashi: not affected by this uh okay bob you can hold on to the side of the ship for a while so the wind
UNKNOWN: don't sweep you uh jack you should be fine but you're not affected by this uh okay bob you can
Kakashi: hold on to the side of the ship for a while so you don't get swept off the ship and you up skip
Kakashi: you know never give short section approaches by yourself because you are feeling yourself
Jack: getting pulled toward that source uh so just dumbling a bit and yeah uh as lu just flies upward
Kakashi: toward this side uh can you give him yeah can you give me a stranger for you to catch him
Baptiste: or dexterity whatever you prefer i gotta quite a bit really many because when weather's going to be interesting next time for sure everyone does find out what its doing tonight whatever determining whether you against the wind is in our favor we are definitely a group of people who work with you for a Physicians a good thing for our cards uhetter than fear we're not and we're just
Kakashi: oh yeah you did crit okay as lu like flies by you you just catch its leg and like grab it uh
Kakashi: into your arms and uh you see uh surprisingly he is not affected at all uh trey is like at the
Kakashi: corner same with uh julie they're like all like planted very firmly on the ship uh as you start
Kakashi: to see like these flowing red hair in the sky as the speed of the force that is incoming keeps
Kakashi: increasing and increasing and the uh pull starts to get looser and looser uh baptiste can you give
UNKNOWN: me a constitution save please i was about to just like take a bow
SPEAKER_08: okay what do you want to do
Kakashi: nothing oh nice never mind uh as you see mira is like flying in fist first as all this like wind
Kakashi: flows around her she is going to just land straight into your fist that you just put out
Kakashi: uh and you get dragged 20 feet let me see another five
Kakashi: uh with loo in one of your arms as you get like pushed back as mirror lands
UNKNOWN: in front of you uh can everyone make another config even me no you don't need to
Kakashi: i'm just seeing who like falls over through the shock wave uh jack you're good bob you
Kakashi: just stumbled down uh roma you're inside you're not affected and the rest of you are gonna be here
Kakashi: should be fine as well uh all right as soon as mira lands on the ship you see the beast like
UNKNOWN: starts to uh get away temporarily and just like submerges into the water hello mira
Kakashi: you just thought you could just show up here and have no consequences huh
SPEAKER_08: trey trey just runs away at this point and he hides behind you jack
UNKNOWN: captain i had nothing to do with this at all don't blame trey yes okay so who should i be
UNKNOWN: we'll be doing no person
UNKNOWN: i thought he was gonna say roma
Roma: well
Jack: didn't
SPEAKER_08: didn't thompson tell us to come here yeah yeah i don't know if he's gonna ride on thompson or not
Kakashi: yeah no we're just saying yeah uh she uh
Kakashi: like turns around and like kind of stretches her neck like rolls around her arms and she
Kakashi: turns back around as she rolls up her sleeves
Kakashi: and you can
Kakashi: you can feel
Kakashi: you can feel like the wind kind of like uh flowing around her as she's like moving one step at a time towards you uh uh do you have anything to say
SPEAKER_04: i'm just bracing for impact
UNKNOWN: uh as you start to
Baptiste: no i'm gonna set lou down
SPEAKER_08: yeah lou just immediately just runs off as soon as you let him go
SPEAKER_08: down he just runs off
UNKNOWN: um
UNKNOWN: uh
Kakashi: she starts walking slowly slowly
Kakashi: as your body starts to shift into your
Kakashi: void form
Kakashi: uh
Kakashi: she keeps walking
Kakashi: keeps walking
Kakashi: and
Kakashi: her both of her arms are up
UNKNOWN: uh
Kakashi: but right before
Kakashi: the impact
Kakashi: that you were
Kakashi: completely like expecting
Kakashi: to come
Kakashi: she just grabs you
Kakashi: and lifts you off your feet
Kakashi: and just
UNKNOWN: hugs you and puts you down i can tell how happy i am to see one of us again
UNKNOWN: it's been months since i've heard from anyone else it might not feel like it but i am glad to
UNKNOWN: see you baptiste intimate is the same era all right okay um let's catch up more uh when you
Kakashi: arrive to our ship trey lead them to the ship as she starts to like uh prepare for launch as
Jack: burst through the air and just flies off uh okay a quick description of mira mira is almost as tall
Kakashi: as king for you jack she's almost as tall with red hair um uh green eyes she has like red uh green
Kakashi: rose and she's like a little bit more like a little bit more like a little bit more like a
Kakashi: uh like a monk's training garb or something like that and she has like a single bracelet on her
UNKNOWN: right hand uh and yeah that's about it all right uh trey at this point comes uh out of behind of
Kakashi: jack and he approaches baptiste and he goes he puts his uh hands in your hands and she goes
SPEAKER_09: oh you have to teach me how to do that how did you do that
UNKNOWN: even i don't right okay oh well captain was in a bad mood surprising me this made it better
UNKNOWN: all right crew follow my lead
UNKNOWN: and he points this way uh as uh
Kakashi: um kate starts to turn the wheel toward that part uh julie runs up and she like makes like a
Kakashi: small whistle roma can you make another save another concept you see she is like trying to
Kakashi: whistle but there's no actual sound coming out oh god roma you're gonna you're gonna
SPEAKER_08: fucking fall on the floor just being in excruciating pain
Baptiste: does roma come
Kakashi: no no he doesn't come to the whistle he just hears the whistle
Roma: uh as you're gonna see roma like trying to like pull food out of like this like
Roma: little doorway you just see in a shit
Kakashi: yeah the sound subsides after a while uh as you see julie gets getting on top of the
Kakashi: uh sea beast
Kakashi: and she goes trey it's not that way it's that way
Kakashi: as she turns around uh on the sea beast and starts to lead oh yeah that way
Kakashi: um and trey goes well i'm not really good with navigating um you should probably follow
UNKNOWN: the sea king all right
Kakashi: uh and i guess you start to follow the sea beast to miras
UNKNOWN: uh stronghold let me move you there okay can you guys see
Jack: still on the ship yeah still the ocean part let me move you guys here
SPEAKER_07: can you see hey it's my guys
Kakashi: guys uh all right from afar you can't really notice a lot of people on the ship uh
Kakashi: but as you like turn the ship around closer and closer uh jack you will be first to notice
Kakashi: king and queen on the deck as they wave hello to you uh and julie will at this point get
Kakashi: off of the sea beast uh okay trey was here right yeah and she just runs in uh to one
Kakashi: of the rooms of the uh ship and the sea beast's
UNKNOWN: starts to like go back into the water hey uh good luck what am i looking at that's all you
Kakashi: uh as uh kate at this point like lays down a plank so you can cross to the other ship
Baptiste: i'll go first uh as you start to like get on the
Kakashi: yeah you can pass through yeah as you uh like go get on top of the ship you see a guy
Kakashi: at the shore uh just like uh having a cigarette and he looks at you and he like spits on the
Kakashi: ground he throws down the cigarette and like he crushes it with his leg and he starts to
Kakashi: get up onto the uh onto mirror ship he's gonna be there
UNKNOWN: in a bit but before that everyone else can make it through uh trey's gonna uh not kate is gonna
Kakashi: be on the ship for a while unless he's called on and
Kakashi: to trey goes into like uh the same room that um what do you call okay julie head into all right
Kakashi: let's go
Kakashi: so jack let's start with you then
Kakashi: all right you walk up to both king and queen queen walks up to you and she goes
Kakashi: so how's it going you made it here pretty quickly yes um guys we have to build you or whatever
UNKNOWN: is he i would like to hear about that later
UNKNOWN: but for now uh you might be surprised to see us here huh
Kakashi: yeah well they took this up uh onto the side of the sea and i'm gonna go back soon we just had to
Kakashi: make sure that the giuseppe don't make any move on the boss yet um
Kakashi: oh yeah uh a small thing i might have asked mira to
UNKNOWN: to take you in for a while so you might have to go through some
UNKNOWN: rough housing they should be fine as long as i don't have to throw drunkards out every day is
UNKNOWN: fine i guess uh king kind of looks down at you
Kakashi: and he goes my man you will be wishing by the end of this that you will have stayed back
Kakashi: anyway i think we should head out darling um before
Kakashi: our no gets
Jack: can i huddle quickly a bit like private
UNKNOWN: uh with who my guys yeah okay
Kakashi: quick site huddle all right so you can ask them to maybe have a conversation first
UNKNOWN: okay okay also there's something we need to talk about
Kakashi: i think it's best if we um talk about it here come uh she leads you like to the other side of the ship
Kakashi: and she goes go ahead
UNKNOWN: two things apparently ghost week dude drank all the money away
Jack: and he's somewhere on the island
Jack: apparently ghost week dude drank all the money away and he's somewhere on the island
Jack: if you want to have a private talk.
Kakashi: Who drank all the money away?
Jack: She probably knows who I talk about.
Jack: I'm talking about Linus, right?
Kakashi: Oh, oh, oh, oh, him.
Kakashi: Okay, okay.
UNKNOWN: Yeah.
UNKNOWN: Oh.
UNKNOWN: I see.
Kakashi: Unfortunately,
Kakashi: as much as I would like to
Kakashi: get to that bastard,
Kakashi: we don't have that much time
Kakashi: and I would not like to get
Kakashi: Giuseppe eyes on us anytime soon.
Kakashi: We'll
Kakashi: look into it.
Kakashi: It's the best we can do.
Kakashi: Anyway, say hi to Arno.
Kakashi: He's headed this way.
Kakashi: You see this, like, guy in a suit
Kakashi: that you have seen around
Kakashi: the
Kakashi: casino
Kakashi: from time to time
Kakashi: walk up to you and he goes,
Kakashi: You called for backup?
Kakashi: When?
Kakashi: Uh, Jack?
Jack: There's a name.
Kakashi: Okay, mind telling me who the hell these guys are?
Kakashi: Because if they're here
Kakashi: for backup
Kakashi: and we're just sitting there
Kakashi: on our hands
Kakashi: and these guys are gathering
Kakashi: more fighters on their side,
Kakashi: it's not
Kakashi: the best outcome for us, is it?
Kakashi: These bastards think they can
Kakashi: get one over us.
Kakashi: Don't they?
UNKNOWN: As much of an idiot they are,
Jack: they sometimes are surprisingly effective
Jack: if the newspapers are
Jack: correct in all their endeavors.
Kakashi: I don't care about what they say
Kakashi: in the newspapers.
Kakashi: I only care about
Kakashi: the boss's wish.
Jack: Right. I've only been there for
Jack: two days? Three days?
UNKNOWN: I'm only listening
Kakashi: to this bullshit because
Kakashi: Queen
Kakashi: managed to convince me.
Kakashi: I'm gonna sit tight
Kakashi: for now.
Kakashi: I'm getting the ship around.
Kakashi: You both be ready to leave.
Kakashi: Are you coming with, Jack?
Jack: I'm gonna look at her.
Jack: Okay, for a second.
Jack: Do we really have to stay here?
Kakashi: She looks back.
Kakashi: She goes,
Kakashi: We're just doing what's best for you.
Jack: Yeah, yeah.
Kakashi: Alright, then.
Kakashi: We'll see you later, Jack.
Kakashi: Oh, you.
Kakashi: You, too, do you?
Kakashi: We'll see about that
Kakashi: when you get home.
Kakashi: They both start to
Kakashi: move behind Arno
Kakashi: as Arno gets down
Kakashi: and he starts to, like,
Kakashi: swim down into the ocean
Kakashi: as he tries to bring around
Kakashi: their sub.
Kakashi: Both King and Queen
Kakashi: get off the ship at this point
UNKNOWN: as they wait for the sub
Kakashi: to come around.
Kakashi: Alright.
Kakashi: In that time,
Kakashi: you see
Kakashi: Mira kind of, like, sitting
Kakashi: in a corner, like, kind of
Kakashi: blanking into the
Kakashi: like, skies
Kakashi: and you see Thompson
Kakashi: approaching you, Roma,
Kakashi: Baptiste, and
Kakashi: Bob, and he, like,
Kakashi: one by one approaches
Kakashi: each one of you as he
Kakashi: greets
Kakashi: everyone.
UNKNOWN: Hello, Thompson.
UNKNOWN: Um,
Kakashi: um,
Kakashi: it's fine, you guys can call me Tom.
Kakashi: You don't have to be
Kakashi: that formal with me.
SPEAKER_04: Thompson Tom.
SPEAKER_04: What up, Bim?
SPEAKER_04: Oh, and there is the beast.
Kakashi: Hello, Roma.
Kakashi: I believe this is the first time
Kakashi: me meeting you or
SPEAKER_07: Bob, is it correct?
Roma: Yep, I don't know him.
UNKNOWN: Alright.
Kakashi: Well, it's, uh, nice to meet you.
Kakashi: Um, you can look around, there's, uh, a lot of people that are here.
Kakashi: Um, you can look around, there's, uh, a lot of people that are here. So, uh, I'm gonna go around the ship,
Kakashi: hang about, maybe talk to
Kakashi: the rest of the crew.
Kakashi: Uh, Baptiste, if you can
Kakashi: come with me, Captain would like a
Kakashi: private word.
Bob: Hey, boss, what do you want me and Bob to do?
Bob: I don't know about you,
Bob: I'm gonna go get some sleep.
Roma: Shut up, Bob.
Kakashi: Maybe you should go get some sleep as well.
Kakashi: Uh, word of advice,
Kakashi: I would not let
Kakashi: my guard down around Julie.
Kakashi: So just be careful about her.
Bob: Oh, shit.
Bob: Roma, that's for you.
Bob: Hey, Roma, go play with Julie.
Roma: Which one's Julie?
UNKNOWN: Which one's Julie?
Kakashi: The, the kid.
Bob: The kid? Oh, she,
Bob: she need a phone.
Bob: Bob is gonna go in the opposite direction of Julie.
SPEAKER_08: Alright, so, are you going back
SPEAKER_08: to your ship?
UNKNOWN: Probably.
Bob: Hey, Kate, you know that you're much
Bob: better than them.
Bob: You're gonna see Roma waddling off.
Bob: Julie!
Kakashi: Uh, as you, like,
Kakashi: enter one of the rooms that Julie
Kakashi: and, uh,
Kakashi: Trey are in, Trey is just, like,
Kakashi: lying on his, like, small, like,
Kakashi: cushion-type, made, like,
Kakashi: kind of, like, rag-tag, like,
Kakashi: just bunch of pillows thrown down
Kakashi: on the floor as he's,
Kakashi: like, just lying on them.
Kakashi: Maybe resting his wounds or whatever.
Kakashi: And, uh,
Kakashi: Julie is just, like, playing with, like,
Kakashi: small, like, kaiju,
Kakashi: like, wooden, like,
Kakashi: beasts. Uh, she
Kakashi: looks around and she goes, Hey!
Kakashi: How are you?
Roma: Hey, you said you need food for somebody.
Roma: Crunch? Crash?
Kakashi: Crunch, crunch, yeah, yeah. He's, uh,
Kakashi: he's gone to sleep, probably.
Kakashi: You can leave it out. He will,
Kakashi: he will get, get it when he's up.
Roma: Okay, where do you want me
Roma: to leave it out at? Uh,
Kakashi: usually we feed him,
Kakashi: uh, yeah, just put it somewhere around there.
Roma: Okay,
Roma: I'mma put it on your dick.
Kakashi: Alright.
Kakashi: She just goes back to, like,
Kakashi: playing with her, like,
Kakashi: small kaiju monsters.
Roma: Can I, can I look to see if one of
Roma: those is, like, a rare monster that Roma
Roma: likes?
Kakashi: Uh, sure,
UNKNOWN: sure. What do you, what do you want?
UNKNOWN: Just a normal roll? Like a d20?
Kakashi: Uh, yeah, just do a d20, and if
Kakashi: it's, like, higher than 15, I'll
Kakashi: say it's one of the,
Kakashi: yeah, alright.
Kakashi: Yeah, you notice one of
Kakashi: the monsters that
Kakashi: you are aware of.
UNKNOWN: Yeah, how'd you
Kakashi: know? Do you like kaijus
Kakashi: too?
UNKNOWN: Oh, nice.
Roma: How, how much?
Kakashi: What do you mean, how much?
Roma: Okay.
Kakashi: On one condition, though.
Roma: What? You let me pet
UNKNOWN: you. What?
Kakashi: On your head.
Roma: Say less if I get that.
Kakashi: Alright. Can you do animal handling?
Kakashi: No, no, it's not animal
UNKNOWN: handling. Alright.
Kakashi: Uh, okay, as soon
Kakashi: as she, like, touches your
Kakashi: head, uh, can you make a
Kakashi: wisdom save?
Roma: Please fail. Please fail.
Roma: I mean, you can
UNKNOWN: choose to fail. No, no,
Kakashi: that's not, that won't be fair.
Kakashi: Uh, Roma, as soon as she, like,
Kakashi: touches your head, you just,
Kakashi: like, kind of lose consciousness for
Kakashi: a second, uh,
Kakashi: and you, like, feel compelled
Kakashi: to just listen to her
Kakashi: every, uh, word.
Kakashi: But, uh,
Kakashi: you see, like, um,
Kakashi: Trey, like, kind of, like,
Kakashi: grabs her hand and, like,
Kakashi: takes it away, and he goes,
Kakashi: Now, Julie, we don't
Kakashi: hurt our friends.
Kakashi: Okay? You can do it with
Kakashi: CBs, not with friends.
Kakashi: Roma is
Kakashi: mink. He is not,
Kakashi: he's not an animal, okay?
UNKNOWN: That's bad. Uh,
Kakashi: she, like, looks
Kakashi: at him, she looks at his
Kakashi: hand, grabbing her hand,
Kakashi: and she just flips around and
Kakashi: fucking kicks his, kicks his
Kakashi: face, and
UNKNOWN: uh,
Kakashi: alright.
Kakashi: And you just see
Kakashi: him, like, fly to the other side of the room.
Kakashi: And she
Kakashi: looks at you, Roma, and she goes,
UNKNOWN: I'm sorry. Here.
Kakashi: Here's your
Kakashi: kaiju.
UNKNOWN: You gonna look, like, it's gonna look like
Roma: you know when a little kid gets, like,
Roma: their favorite toy from a store?
Roma: Like, the pure happiness walk?
Roma: You gonna see that
Roma: from Roma.
Kakashi: Nice.
Kakashi: Uh, she
Kakashi: at this point just runs to, uh,
Kakashi: Trey, and she, like,
Kakashi: ats his head a couple of times.
Kakashi: As he's, like, still reeling
Kakashi: in from the fucking hit.
Kakashi: Um,
Kakashi: alright, let's
Kakashi: move to Baptiste. Okay.
Kakashi: I'll move you to the captain's quarters.
UNKNOWN: Uh, I'll move everyone to the
Kakashi: captain's quarters. There you go.
Kakashi: Alright, uh, as you
Kakashi: head inside, uh,
Kakashi: Mira already, like, steps
Kakashi: inside a bit before
Kakashi: uh, Trey asks you to.
Kakashi: And she sits down.
Kakashi: Uh, Trey just, like,
Kakashi: closes the door and stands
UNKNOWN: uh,
Kakashi: guard at the door.
UNKNOWN: And,
Kakashi: um, she kind of sighs
UNKNOWN: and she goes,
Kakashi: uh,
Kakashi: uh, not Trey,
Kakashi: fucking Tom. I forgot.
SPEAKER_08: This is why I
SPEAKER_08: have, like, the same names.
SPEAKER_08: Yeah, the same, like,
Kakashi: T word, and it, like, triggers
Kakashi: a wheel. It's, like, the same name.
Kakashi: I'm, I'm bad, man. I don't know what to
Kakashi: tell ya. Uh, Mira
Kakashi: kind of sighs and, like,
Kakashi: sits down. She looks at you.
Kakashi: And she looks at Thompson and she goes,
Kakashi: uh, let me
Kakashi: guess. You called them here,
Kakashi: yes? And Thompson
Kakashi: kinda nods.
Kakashi: And, uh, she
Kakashi: looks at you and goes,
Kakashi: uh, well,
Kakashi: I suppose it's best that you are
UNKNOWN: here. So,
Kakashi: this is
Kakashi: the general layout
Kakashi: of the place. You should familiarize
Kakashi: yourself with it.
Kakashi: Uh, she points out, like, a
Kakashi: group of islands,
Kakashi: kind of, like, joined together, but they're
Kakashi: uh, like, separated, uh,
Kakashi: by sea somewhat.
Kakashi: Uh, and on the
Kakashi: map, you can see, uh,
Kakashi: the island that you left from,
Kakashi: which was called Westtown.
Kakashi: And the island that you are on right
Kakashi: now, in the cluster of Juniper Islands,
Kakashi: is, um,
Kakashi: Yorktown.
Kakashi: And there's one more island, uh,
Kakashi: on the northern side, uh,
Kakashi: which is, like, marked as Brooktown.
Kakashi: So, uh,
Kakashi: that's the cluster of islands
Kakashi: that you, uh, that
Kakashi: formed the Juniper Islands.
Kakashi: And, uh, this is the layout
Kakashi: of the whole place.
Kakashi: Um, and she continues
Kakashi: and she says
Kakashi: to you, um,
Kakashi: that you are
Kakashi: here. We will
Kakashi: have to inform
Kakashi: the Giuseppis that I have
Kakashi: more people
Kakashi: with me before they find out their
Kakashi: own way. I think it's
Kakashi: best to keep everything transparent
Kakashi: before they misunderstand our
Kakashi: intentions.
UNKNOWN: So, I think it's
Kakashi: best to take everyone with
Kakashi: us for a small trip
Kakashi: to Yorktown.
Kakashi: We will meet the head of Giuseppi.
Kakashi: We'll let them know.
Kakashi: And then, I think immediately
Kakashi: we can start with your training.
Kakashi: I suppose you're
Kakashi: already aware of the situation that is
Kakashi: currently going on.
UNKNOWN: Uh, at this point Thompson kind of
Kakashi: steps in as, uh,
Kakashi: Mira kind of, like,
Kakashi: lays her head on the,
Kakashi: uh, table.
Kakashi: Uh, Thompson steps in and
Kakashi: he explains, like, what has
Kakashi: been going on so far.
Kakashi: Uh, he starts by telling
Kakashi: you that the, initially
Kakashi: why they were called here
Kakashi: was because of the Giuseppi
Kakashi: family making accusations that
Kakashi: the Capones have been
Kakashi: infiltrating in their region
Kakashi: and, uh,
Kakashi: like, peddling drugs
Kakashi: in their area.
Kakashi: Uh, so Blackhand asks
Kakashi: Mira to, uh, come
Kakashi: here, uh, in his stead.
Kakashi: And try to negotiate or try to
Kakashi: find out, like, what has been happening.
Kakashi: Uh, unfortunately,
Kakashi: the negotiations were
Kakashi: happening, like, uh, every few
Kakashi: weeks. They were meeting together, trying to
Kakashi: resolve the issues. But only
Kakashi: like, uh, three, four
Kakashi: days ago, someone made
Kakashi: an attempt on the life of
Kakashi: Lorenzo Capone, the current head of
Kakashi: the Capone family. And,
Kakashi: uh, the Capone family
Kakashi: insists that there were the
Kakashi: Giuseppis that were
Kakashi: responsible for that. But
Kakashi: since, uh, Lorenzo
Kakashi: Capone himself is
Kakashi: under, uh, like a
Kakashi: temporary coma or something, uh,
Kakashi: while he's being fixed,
Kakashi: uh, everything is
Kakashi: calm for now. We don't know what will
Kakashi: happen once he wakes up.
Baptiste: So, here we are.
Baptiste: What do they have
Baptiste: to do with everything? Oh, yeah.
Kakashi: Uh, King and Queen,
Kakashi: uh, are supposedly
Kakashi: uh, poured on
Kakashi: off the
Kakashi: Capone family's gang, a smaller
Kakashi: gang, uh, they're called the Royal Flesh Gang.
Kakashi: And I think
Kakashi: the guy that you're traveling with
Kakashi: is also part
UNKNOWN: of them, right? Jack?
Baptiste: So that's what
Baptiste: his name comes from.
Kakashi: Yes.
Kakashi: Um, well,
Kakashi: that's not their real names, but, you
Kakashi: know, this is what we have to work with.
Kakashi: Anyway, uh,
Kakashi: the captain,
Kakashi: uh,
Kakashi: was asked by those two
Kakashi: to train the other guy as
Kakashi: well. Now I see it
Kakashi: sounds a bit
Kakashi: weird, like, why would
Kakashi: we train someone from the other side?
Kakashi: But Captain and King have
Kakashi: some history, and she owes him, like,
Kakashi: a favor or something, so she's
Kakashi: accepting it for now.
Kakashi: We'll see how it goes.
Kakashi: Uh, so,
Kakashi: my suggestion is, gather up
Kakashi: your crew, and we will, uh,
Kakashi: leave in 20 to 30 minutes.
Kakashi: And you can
Kakashi: inform your crew about
Kakashi: what's going to happen,
Kakashi: and, uh,
Kakashi: maybe take in Jack
Kakashi: for a while with your crew.
Baptiste: That's to be seen.
UNKNOWN: Uh, that's fine.
Kakashi: Um, alright.
Kakashi: We'll get them ready.
Kakashi: We will be leaving in 20 minutes or so.
Kakashi: Alright, let me move you to
Kakashi: Stronghold again.
UNKNOWN: Alright.
Kakashi: Uh, alright, Bob, what are you doing?
Kakashi: Sleeping?
Bob: And crying.
UNKNOWN: What?
UNKNOWN: Okay.
Bob: That's just the default.
Kakashi: Alright, uh,
Kakashi: as you step out, uh,
Kakashi: off the Captain's quarters,
Kakashi: you see Roma with, like, a
Kakashi: small, like, wooden toy in his hands.
Kakashi: Uh,
Kakashi: while he's, like, walking around the deck.
Kakashi: You see Jack in a corner
Kakashi: saying, like, waving goodbyes
Kakashi: to, like, a small sub
Kakashi: that's sinking on this side.
Kakashi: Uh, and
Kakashi: he starts to move towards,
Kakashi: I guess, the deck.
UNKNOWN: I'll see
Baptiste: Roma and I'll just go,
Baptiste: it looks like you're fine.
Baptiste: And he sounds very disappointed when he says it.
SPEAKER_13: You all see, all Roma's
SPEAKER_13: gonna be is like,
SPEAKER_13: dude,
SPEAKER_13: aren't you bad about the
SPEAKER_04: The what?
Roma: What, what? And then you're gonna see him, like, stuff it
Roma: in his, like, little jacket.
Roma: What, boss?
SPEAKER_13: Incompetent.
SPEAKER_13: What you mean, incompetent? I'm very
SPEAKER_13: competent.
Baptiste: And then he'll just start walking back to our ship.
Kakashi: Alright.
Kakashi: Uh, Jack, what are you doing?
SPEAKER_08: Roma, what are you doing? Going back on the ship?
Roma: Nah, well, yeah, I'm
Roma: gonna start bringing food over from
Roma: our ship to their ship.
UNKNOWN: That he made.
UNKNOWN: Uh, Jack,
Kakashi: what are you doing? Are you staying on the ship or
Kakashi: moving back
Kakashi: as well?
Jack: Uh, well,
Jack: going down
Jack: from the upper deck,
Jack: I'm just gonna, like,
Jack: so, um,
Jack: be around for a while.
Kakashi: Uh, Thompson is, like,
Kakashi: standing in front of the captain's
Kakashi: quarters, and he looks at you and goes,
UNKNOWN: Uh,
Kakashi: can I talk to you
SPEAKER_07: for a moment here?
Roma: So, Jack.
UNKNOWN: What's your name?
UNKNOWN: Our captain, um,
SPEAKER_07: for better or worse, is
SPEAKER_07: a bit too trustworthy.
UNKNOWN: But I,
SPEAKER_07: on the other hand, am not so trustworthy
Kakashi: of you or the
Kakashi: other Royal Flush Gang members.
Kakashi: I'm gonna say
Kakashi: this once, and you better take this
UNKNOWN: to heart. You fuck with
Kakashi: us, or Baptiste's
UNKNOWN: crew, there's no one
Kakashi: who's gonna come and save you here.
UNKNOWN: You understand?
UNKNOWN: Okay.
Jack: Did you make
Jack: confidence?
Jack: Probably they would. Wait, actually,
Jack: they probably would have, but I'm just gonna
UNKNOWN: What is there?
UNKNOWN: Wait, what?
UNKNOWN: Well, there
Jack: probably would have been, like, something
Jack: done, but I'm gonna
Jack: ask him, was there some
Jack: signs of me staying
Jack: here and being trained or whatever
Jack: the plan is now?
UNKNOWN: Well, yeah,
Jack: I'm asking, because I don't know.
UNKNOWN: No,
SPEAKER_09: I think they already told you,
UNKNOWN: right? Yeah, well,
UNKNOWN: yeah,
Jack: but I'm asking him as well to, like,
Jack: talk to him
Jack: further about it.
Kakashi: So I'm asking him, was there
UNKNOWN: Oh, you're
Kakashi: asking him if there was a conversation
Kakashi: about training? Yeah, yeah, yeah. Okay, okay.
Kakashi: I thought you were asking me.
Jack: No, or a contract or whatever.
Kakashi: There's
Kakashi: no formal contract. It was
Kakashi: more of a handshake agreement.
UNKNOWN: Mira's
Kakashi: only doing this because she thinks
Kakashi: that
Kakashi: King won't betray her
Kakashi: or do something stupid.
Kakashi: Either way,
Kakashi: even outside of
Kakashi: that thread that I just made, I want you
Kakashi: to feel comfortable
Kakashi: and be part
Kakashi: of the crew. So,
Kakashi: welcome aboard.
Kakashi: And he, like, puts out his hand.
UNKNOWN: I'm gonna shake it.
UNKNOWN: He starts walking.
Jack: No, no, no.
Jack: Talk to him.
UNKNOWN: Yeah.
Jack: We live by the rules that we
UNKNOWN: cash in our
Jack: we rather cash in our favours than
Jack: well, not our favours, but
Jack: what's the word?
UNKNOWN: Fuck.
Roma: I'm losing words.
Roma: No.
Kakashi: Cashing in the chips? What?
Jack: No, well,
Jack: never mind.
Jack: If we make a deal, we live by those.
Kakashi: I would expect you to.
UNKNOWN: See?
Kakashi: Alright. Anything else?
Jack: Yeah, the thread you made.
Jack: I have one.
Jack: I also have a
Jack: favour to cash in, and if
Jack: you were to go around,
Jack: someone would come.
Jack: And that would be a very bad day for you.
Roma: And I'm gonna walk off.
Jack: I'm reversing
Jack: that thread, bitch.
SPEAKER_08: He's doing a Juno
SPEAKER_08: reverse.
Jack: You make a thread against me?
Jack: What if I do one?
Kakashi: That's fine.
Kakashi: Okay, you land on the
Kakashi: ship.
SPEAKER_00: Baptiste, what do you have to say?
Baptiste: I am just
Baptiste: getting the crew together.
Baptiste: Giving them a brief
Baptiste: rundown to let them know we're heading to
Baptiste: the island.
Baptiste: And to prepare for
Baptiste: a tough couple.
Baptiste: A tough time to come.
Baptiste: There's going to be
Baptiste: a lot going on these next couple
Baptiste: coming days.
UNKNOWN: But, who knows, maybe I'll
Baptiste: finally whip some of you into shape.
Baptiste: He'll look at Roma.
UNKNOWN: But,
UNKNOWN: it's a very much
UNKNOWN: needed time.
Roma: He's gonna nudge
Roma: Jack and be like,
Roma: he said, whip us into shape.
Bob: I can't wait
Bob: till Mira.
Baptiste: Prepare yourselves. We set out soon.
UNKNOWN: And then he'll approach
Baptiste: Cayde individually.
UNKNOWN: You saw Mira
SPEAKER_04: earlier. That's
SPEAKER_04: one of the fleet commanders
UNKNOWN: from Blackhand's
SPEAKER_00: Yes.
SPEAKER_00: I gathered that.
SPEAKER_04: She's going to be training us
UNKNOWN: in these coming
SPEAKER_04: days.
UNKNOWN: It's
SPEAKER_04: up to you whether or not you would like
SPEAKER_04: to participate.
SPEAKER_00: No, I would definitely
SPEAKER_00: like to be part of that.
SPEAKER_04: Just know you're not forced to.
SPEAKER_04: Just
Roma: if it ever gets too far.
Baptiste: Once he says that, I'll put a hand on his shoulder.
Baptiste: You're a good kid, Cayde.
Roma: Okay.
Roma: Isn't Cayde like an adult?
Kakashi: No, he's 16.
Kakashi: I've said it multiple times.
Kakashi: I've said he's 16.
Roma: So, time out. We have a 16
Roma: year old piloting our ship.
SPEAKER_08: He's been over this.
Jack: Roma.
SPEAKER_08: You know that Luffy
SPEAKER_08: is 16 too, right? At the start of
SPEAKER_08: his journey.
Kakashi: He's 17, but basically
Kakashi: 16.
Jack: Now he's 19.
Kakashi: Now he's 19, but at the time he was
Kakashi: 17.
Baptiste: He lives to 19?
Kakashi: Yeah, right now he's 19.
Roma: That's only two years.
Roma: 17 and 19.
Roma: Look at what he did in the whole
UNKNOWN: two years.
UNKNOWN: Okay, everyone can
Kakashi: prepare because then
Kakashi: you're gonna go on land after this.
Kakashi: You will have no inventory
Kakashi: of the ship, so take everything
Kakashi: you need and
Kakashi: yeah.
Baptiste: Can
Baptiste: Lou participate in the
Baptiste: training?
Roma: What? That'd be dope.
Baptiste: Can Lou participate in the training?
Baptiste: That would be dope.
SPEAKER_09: I mean, it's up to you if you want
SPEAKER_09: Lou...
Kakashi: Sorry.
Kakashi: Keep Lou
Kakashi: on and safe with
Kakashi: the rest who will not be joining
Kakashi: you, which will basically be
Kakashi: just
Kakashi: Thompson and
Kakashi: what's her face?
Kakashi: Julie. They're gonna stay back
Kakashi: and you're gonna go with Trey and
Kakashi: Mira.
Roma: Is Trey joining us?
Roma: Yeah, he's kind of vital
Kakashi: to the training part.
UNKNOWN: Julie!
Baptiste: Julie is gonna take my dog
Baptiste: for me so I don't trust her.
UNKNOWN: Oops.
Kakashi: It's up to you
Kakashi: again if you want to keep Lou with you.
Roma: You want to level up Lou?
Roma: With me.
Roma: I feel like Lou's gonna have some hidden talents.
Kakashi: You want to
Kakashi: keep Lou with you then?
Kakashi: Yes.
Kakashi: Alright, so
Kakashi: I'll say...okay prepare
Kakashi: whatever you need to and
Kakashi: let me know if you're
Kakashi: prepared. Okay, also
Bob: Baptist just did raise a valid
Bob: concern. I'll probably also take my stag with him.
Bob: You don't have to take the token.
Bob: Yeah, yeah, yeah. That's fine.
Bob: Alone with Julie.
Kakashi: Yeah. Okay.
Kakashi: Kate is gonna
Kakashi: like
Kakashi: leave something
Kakashi: to like feed the
Kakashi: deer and the stag
Kakashi: on the ship and he will maybe
Kakashi: form Thompson
Kakashi: and someone to
Kakashi: like from time to time
Kakashi: go and feed them because you don't know how long
Kakashi: you'll be out there.
Kakashi: So he's gonna prepare all of
Kakashi: that and
Kakashi: he's gonna
Kakashi: move them onto...
Kakashi: Okay, so the thing is
Kakashi: you're keeping your stag
Kakashi: with you, right? You're taking the stag with you?
UNKNOWN: Yeah.
UNKNOWN: Now what?
Kakashi: She...
Bob: If you're coming it might not be a problem.
Kakashi: Yeah, she will be taking her ship.
Kakashi: So you will leave your ship behind and
Kakashi: under the protection of Julie
UNKNOWN: and Thompson. Baptist.
Roma: She's definitely stealing those animals.
Roma: Yeah, so the...
Kakashi: No, none of them
Kakashi: are like actual
Kakashi: shipwrights.
Kakashi: I mean Thompson knows a little
Kakashi: bit to like keep the ship
Kakashi: afloat but none of them are actually like shipwrights
Kakashi: or anything.
Baptiste: Can I ask Mira if she knows a bramble in the
Baptiste: house?
Kakashi: I mean you can go and talk to her when you're about to leave.
Kakashi: That was the thing I wanted to do
Kakashi: or I forgot.
Kakashi: Just keep that in mind.
Kakashi: Alright.
Kakashi: She is
Kakashi: going to head out with
Kakashi: Trey as
Kakashi: both of them land on the ship
Kakashi: and they
Kakashi: ask if everyone's ready to leave.
Baptiste: Before we go...
UNKNOWN: Yes?
Baptiste: Yeah.
Baptiste: No other bramble
Baptiste: here in the south.
Kakashi: Those bastards scammed me out
Kakashi: of millions of berries.
UNKNOWN: Why?
Baptiste: I'm just going to look at our ship.
UNKNOWN: Oh.
Kakashi: I'll ask the Giuseppis
Kakashi: to maybe fix it up a little bit.
Kakashi: We
Kakashi: can talk about
Kakashi: the...
Kakashi: Actually, can you come here for a bit?
UNKNOWN: Oh.
Roma: Why do you sound so afraid, bro?
Kakashi: Uh...
Kakashi: You see Trey kind of follows
Kakashi: Mira and you onto this
Kakashi: corner as Mira goes
Kakashi: Um...
Kakashi: I was hesitant to ask
Kakashi: this but how much
Kakashi: money do you think you have?
Baptiste: Well...
Kakashi: In the Karoo's treasury.
UNKNOWN: Alright.
Baptiste: With the
Baptiste: 50 million that we were going to use
Baptiste: to get prepared.
Baptiste: But as for actual...
Kakashi: You don't understand my
Kakashi: question. I need, like, cold hard cash.
Baptiste: I was
Baptiste: getting to that. Um...
Baptiste: Collectively?
UNKNOWN: I wouldn't put it
Baptiste: over one million berries.
Roma: Okay. So
Roma: here's the thing. We've been...
Kakashi: No. We've been out here
Kakashi: for about
UNKNOWN: three months
Kakashi: and
Kakashi: Crunch
Kakashi: is
Kakashi: very hard to feed.
Kakashi: And we've been
Kakashi: living off of whatever remained
Kakashi: of
Kakashi: what we fed Crunch.
Kakashi: Now, we don't have a lot of supplies
Kakashi: left. And we've
Kakashi: asked for favors from the Giuseppes
Kakashi: which I don't feel very good about.
Kakashi: And on top of that
Kakashi: if I ask for repairs
Kakashi: without paying them back, there are
Kakashi: the Mafia.
Kakashi: So it might get a bit tense, but
Kakashi: I guess we'll figure it out.
Kakashi: Uh...
Baptiste: I just wanted to ask for Bramble.
Kakashi: Yeah, Bramble...
Kakashi: I don't know. He's in the
Kakashi: south somewhere, but I don't know where.
Kakashi: It's just like all of his locations
Kakashi: are new. And I
Kakashi: met him back in the east.
Baptiste: Is there a casino nearby?
Kakashi: It's a Mafia town.
Kakashi: Of course there's a casino nearby.
Baptiste: You know the saying.
Baptiste: Get even
Baptiste: with everybody.
Kakashi: I'm not taking any part of that.
Kakashi: I'm bad at this.
Kakashi: Okay, I'm just off.
Kakashi: Alright, crew.
Kakashi: Let's get ready.
Kakashi: And turn this shit around and leave.
UNKNOWN: I thought that we were taking Mira's ship.
Kakashi: No, no. Mira's taking...
Kakashi: Oh yeah, Mira should be taking her ship.
Kakashi: Sorry, I forgot.
UNKNOWN: Hold on.
Kakashi: Uh... As...
Kakashi: uh... you guys leave,
Kakashi: uh...
Kakashi: she will ask who's your
Kakashi: helmsman, Baptiste?
Baptiste: I'll introduce her to Cade.
Kakashi: Cade kinda like...
Kakashi: Cade
Kakashi: greets Mira and she
Kakashi: goes, Alright, Cade.
Kakashi: I'm putting my
Kakashi: faith in you in
Kakashi: handling my ship.
Kakashi: You ready?
Kakashi: Alright. Let's get
Kakashi: this shit started.
UNKNOWN: Okay.
Kakashi: Both Julie and
Kakashi: uh...
Kakashi: Thompson get off and
Kakashi: they're gonna bring around the ship and dock
Kakashi: it here where Mira's ship is at
Kakashi: once you leave.
Kakashi: And we will
Kakashi: be off to
Kakashi: another one. Anything you wanna talk
Kakashi: in between?
Kakashi: Or should I just move you to the docks?
Kakashi: You see Mira has like
Kakashi: uh... the black hand flag
Kakashi: on her ship instead of her own flag.
UNKNOWN: By the way.
Baptiste: Oh, she means this.
UNKNOWN: Yeah.
Kakashi: Uh...
Kakashi: As she... as you guys like
Kakashi: bring around the ship outside the waterfall
Kakashi: and you move the... navigate
Kakashi: the ship around to the
Kakashi: closest dock,
Kakashi: uh... you land
Kakashi: at
Kakashi: Yorktown Docks.
Kakashi: Uh... she gets off the ship
Kakashi: uh...
Kakashi: she will ask
Kakashi: Trey to
Kakashi: guide
Kakashi: some of you toward
Kakashi: um...
Kakashi: the training
Kakashi: grounds while some of you can still
Kakashi: uh... go with Mira and
Kakashi: meet up with the Giuseppis.
Kakashi: Who wants to go with Trey? Who wants to go with Mira?
Kakashi: If everyone wants to go with Mira
Kakashi: we can do that too.
Kakashi: But uh...
Kakashi: Cade will
Kakashi: go with
Kakashi: Trey.
Baptiste: I feel like they can become besties.
UNKNOWN: Yeah.
Kakashi: Yeah. Yeah.
Kakashi: Uh... Trey will...
Kakashi: Sorry, Cade will go with Trey.
Kakashi: Roma, uh... Bob.
Roma: Hey boss, you gonna need me?
Roma: Okay, then I'm going.
Baptiste: Okay. Bob?
Bob: Uh... probably going where
Bob: Roma's going.
Kakashi: Uh... so you all
Kakashi: uh... turn like
Kakashi: right from this way and start
Kakashi: heading towards the training grounds.
Kakashi: Jack?
UNKNOWN: See? It would
Jack: not be the best if I go with Mira, but...
Kakashi: Yeah, I mean, uh... they don't know you.
UNKNOWN: Right?
Jack: Well, I'm just... I'll follow Mira.
Kakashi: Yeah. And I think it's the best
Kakashi: chance you have to get
Kakashi: some information.
UNKNOWN: Mm-hmm.
UNKNOWN: Yeah, if you're Lucas
Baptiste: I'll follow.
Kakashi: Uh... so at this point you will
Kakashi: be with Mira,
Kakashi: uh... Baptiste, and...
Kakashi: Jack?
Kakashi: I think that's all right.
Kakashi: Let me go back to the training.
Kakashi: Let me see how many people we have.
Kakashi: Uh...
Kakashi: Me, Mira, Baptiste, and Roma, Bob, and Trey.
Kakashi: All right. Uh... Mira leads
Kakashi: you through the
Kakashi: alleys of this town.
Kakashi: As you just see, like, everyone kind of like
Kakashi: smiling, nodding at Mira, saying
Kakashi: hellos. Uh... she walks
Kakashi: through some of the buildings. You see this
Kakashi: large tavern with
Kakashi: a big board that says
Kakashi: Risky Choice, and
Kakashi: Mira starts to head inside.
Kakashi: Uh...
Kakashi: On your way out,
Kakashi: you bump into this man.
Kakashi: I'm gonna send a picture.
UNKNOWN: Who's that man?
UNKNOWN: Uh... actually, I'll just
Kakashi: add him here so you can see.
UNKNOWN: I'm gonna zoom all the way in.
Kakashi: Uh...
Kakashi: Baptiste, you will bump into
Kakashi: this guy as he
Kakashi: looks at you and he goes,
Kakashi: hey, I'm walking here.
Kakashi: Watch where you're going.
Baptiste: I'm just gonna look him up and down
UNKNOWN: and walk somewhere else.
SPEAKER_09: Rats, you wanna fuck with
SPEAKER_09: me?
UNKNOWN: I'm surprised he doesn't say yeah.
UNKNOWN: Mm-hmm.
Baptiste: Are you sure you wanna fuck with me?
Kakashi: Uh... at this point,
Kakashi: Mira steps in and she
Kakashi: like, looks back and she goes,
Kakashi: Jen, leave it
Kakashi: alone and keep walking before
Kakashi: you get hurt, kid.
Kakashi: Uh... he like, uh...
Kakashi: looks at her
Kakashi: and he looks at you
Kakashi: and uh... I see what's
Kakashi: happening here.
Kakashi: And he keeps walking away
Kakashi: outside of the bar.
SPEAKER_07: I'm gonna move you to the bar now.
UNKNOWN: Uh... I straight here.
Jack: The bar is black.
Jack: There is no bar.
Jack: I'm moving your tokens in.
Kakashi: Give me a second.
Kakashi: Uh... you know what? I'll let everyone
Kakashi: see the bar, so I'll just disable the
Kakashi: token vision. There we go.
Kakashi: I'll bring your
SPEAKER_07: tokens in.
UNKNOWN: I'm Baptiste
SPEAKER_07: and there's Jack.
UNKNOWN: Alright.
Kakashi: As you walk in the bar, it's like, pretty
Kakashi: normal-looking
Kakashi: situation.
Kakashi: Why is Trey here?
Kakashi: Yeah.
Kakashi: You see...
Kakashi: You see a bunch of people
Kakashi: like, sitting around drinking. You see a bunch
Kakashi: of families sitting around having
Kakashi: like, lunch at this time.
Kakashi: And Mira keeps walking
Kakashi: towards the
Kakashi: table as she takes a seat.
Kakashi: And she tells
Kakashi: both of you to take a seat
Kakashi: somewhere as well.
Kakashi: Uh...
Kakashi: You see like, the old lady at the
Kakashi: uh... like,
Kakashi: the pot in between.
Kakashi: She like, gets up from her
Kakashi: uh... chair and she
Kakashi: starts walking towards
Kakashi: uh... Mira.
Kakashi: And they like, uh...
Kakashi: nod at each other. She looks at you
Kakashi: and she goes,
Kakashi: You got some new blood in town,
Kakashi: huh?
Kakashi: What might be your name, young man?
SPEAKER_05: I'm Baptiste.
Kakashi: Baptiste. And you?
Kakashi: Name check, please.
Kakashi: Jack.
Kakashi: Uh... I suppose you want to
Kakashi: meet Ramdan?
UNKNOWN: Uh...
Kakashi: Mira nods.
Kakashi: And she
Kakashi: looks at the man sitting
Kakashi: like, at the corner.
Kakashi: And she kind of nods at him.
Kakashi: He gets up.
Kakashi: And he
Kakashi: uh... starts walking
Kakashi: upstairs here.
Kakashi: Mira gets up and she
Kakashi: says to you, okay, follow me.
Kakashi: Uh... this man
Kakashi: leads you
Kakashi: outside. And you
Kakashi: can see, like, a stairs leading up
Kakashi: to, like, an upper area
Kakashi: of this, uh...
Kakashi: tavern.
Kakashi: Okay, what the fuck, man?
SPEAKER_07: Uh... hello?
SPEAKER_07: Okay.
SPEAKER_07: Uh...
SPEAKER_07: Let's go to the meeting room.
UNKNOWN: I really hope these places
Kakashi: are not, like, one-time places.
Kakashi: And I can reuse them, but we'll
UNKNOWN: see. We'll see. Uh...
Kakashi: Alright. As you head
Kakashi: inside, uh...
Kakashi: the man leads you inside
Kakashi: and he...
Kakashi: uh... walks
Kakashi: through the corridor.
Kakashi: And...
Kakashi: uh... enters one of the rooms
Kakashi: as it opens, as he opens
Kakashi: the room for you guys to enter.
UNKNOWN: Can you guys see this? Everyone?
UNKNOWN: Yes. Everyone can see it, right?
Roma: Oh, yeah. Yeah, that's nice.
Kakashi: Uh... at the head
Kakashi: of the table, you see this guy
Kakashi: sitting on it with, like, uh...
Kakashi: fur coat on.
Kakashi: And, like, some grayish hair.
Kakashi: And a purple jacket
Kakashi: with black vests inside.
Kakashi: As she... as he smiles
Kakashi: and welcomes Mira
Kakashi: inside.
Kakashi: And, uh... the other guy
Kakashi: that led you to
Kakashi: him takes a seat here.
Kakashi: Mira, uh...
Kakashi: uh... heads
Kakashi: toward the
Kakashi: start of the table
Kakashi: and she asks you both to
Kakashi: take a seat as well.
Kakashi: And... uh...
Kakashi: the guy
Kakashi: continues, uh...
Kakashi: and starts with asking, like,
Kakashi: what is happening? Mira fills
Kakashi: him in into
Kakashi: what exactly, uh...
Kakashi: you guys are doing here and stuff like that.
Kakashi: And, uh...
Kakashi: he, like, rings up
Kakashi: Denden Mushi on his desk
Kakashi: as a lot of
Kakashi: people start to fill
Kakashi: in the room one by one.
Kakashi: Uh, the first woman
Kakashi: you see
Kakashi: is
Kakashi: wearing, like, a
Kakashi: fur coat, like, uh...
Kakashi: garment around
Kakashi: her arms and, like,
Kakashi: black, uh, gold stripe
Kakashi: outfit as she
Kakashi: walks in and
Kakashi: takes a seat right, uh...
Kakashi: like, next to this guy.
Kakashi: And you see
Kakashi: another guy with
Kakashi: kind of, like, a dour look
Kakashi: as he, like, steps in
Kakashi: walks past you.
Kakashi: Uh, Jack
Kakashi: and starts to head
Kakashi: toward the other side of the table.
Kakashi: Uh...
Kakashi: as he's walking through, Jack, you also notice
Kakashi: like, as he's, like,
Kakashi: moving step by step
Kakashi: he's leaving, like, ink
Kakashi: marks on the floor
Kakashi: as he moves. Uh...
Kakashi: and then, uh...
Kakashi: a woman kind of just, like, appears
Kakashi: from behind you, Baptiste.
Kakashi: Uh, you don't even notice her
Kakashi: as she, like, takes a seat
Kakashi: right next to you.
Kakashi: And lastly,
Kakashi: the guy that you ran into, Baptiste,
Kakashi: the stork,
Kakashi: uh, walks in
Kakashi: and takes a seat.
Kakashi: And...
Kakashi: finally, the old woman
Kakashi: that you guys met, uh...
Kakashi: uh, at the beginning
Kakashi: also walks in and takes a seat.
UNKNOWN: Can I wink
Baptiste: at him?
Kakashi: Wink at who? The guy in front of you?
Kakashi: Yeah.
Kakashi: Uh, he just looks at you and, like,
Kakashi: uh, gives you, like, an angry
Kakashi: intense look back.
Kakashi: And the
Kakashi: guy at the head of the table
Kakashi: is like,
Kakashi: Welcome. Let me introduce you
Kakashi: to my family.
Kakashi: This right here
Kakashi: on my right side
Kakashi: is my younger sister, Brandy.
Kakashi: Uh, she
Kakashi: nods at you, uh, both.
Kakashi: Uh, this here is Tequila.
UNKNOWN: This here
Kakashi: is my twin brother, Rum.
Kakashi: This here is my
Kakashi: youngest brother, Jin.
Kakashi: That is
Kakashi: Vodka.
Kakashi: And that's my older sister, Whiskey.
Kakashi: And I
SPEAKER_00: am the head of the Giuseppe family.
UNKNOWN: Rum.
SPEAKER_00: It is a pleasure to meet you.
SPEAKER_00: I hope we can accommodate
SPEAKER_00: you well.
SPEAKER_00: Anything you require,
SPEAKER_00: you can just let us know.
SPEAKER_00: I'm glad to see
UNKNOWN: some fine fellas
SPEAKER_00: in our
SPEAKER_00: camp.
SPEAKER_00: I just hope to
SPEAKER_00: see this mess being resolved
SPEAKER_00: before anyone gets hurt.
UNKNOWN: Or shot at
UNKNOWN: in the face. So,
Roma: um,
Roma: anything you'd like to
Roma: talk about,
Roma: my
Roma: friends?
Roma: Mira?
Roma: Um, good. You wanted to
Roma: talk about the ship?
Roma: She kind of whispers to you.
Roma: I did have one
Roma: to discuss.
Roma: Now, of course, of course, my friend.
Roma: Go ahead.
Baptiste: With your influence, do you know of a bramble
Baptiste: in the south?
Roma: Uh, uh,
Roma: that old geezer.
SPEAKER_00: Uh, yes, yes, I know him.
SPEAKER_00: I've been dodging
SPEAKER_00: our
SPEAKER_00: collection calls for a while now, but
SPEAKER_00: we will find him soon enough.
UNKNOWN: Why?
Roma: Does he owe you money as well?
Roma: Let's say we have a
Roma: promissory note
Roma: for brambles
UNKNOWN: that we need
Baptiste: to use to repair our ship.
Kakashi: He shakes around
Kakashi: the glass as he
Kakashi: takes like a sip of
Kakashi: uh, uh,
Kakashi: the drink he has in his hand
Kakashi: and puts it down because
Kakashi: uh,
Kakashi: tequila. Do you mind looking
Kakashi: into the whereabouts of
Kakashi: bramble these days?
UNKNOWN: Uh,
Kakashi: the guy next to him looks at you
Kakashi: Baptiste and goes,
UNKNOWN: uh,
Kakashi: amigo, do you have any details
SPEAKER_09: about, uh,
SPEAKER_09: where I might be able to find
UNKNOWN: him? He's asking me.
UNKNOWN: Yes.
UNKNOWN: I don't think
Jack: I have anything.
Jack: Yeah, otherwise we wouldn't ask, right?
Jack: Yeah.
SPEAKER_09: Let's see.
SPEAKER_09: Not any leads then.
SPEAKER_09: I'll have to...
SPEAKER_09: I'll inform
SPEAKER_09: you in case
UNKNOWN: I find anything. Well,
SPEAKER_09: these are
SPEAKER_09: the head of the family
Kakashi: starts speaking again.
UNKNOWN: Um, these are the only
SPEAKER_00: people you need to
SPEAKER_00: really be aware of. We have
SPEAKER_00: our men walking the streets and
SPEAKER_00: keeping everyone safe.
SPEAKER_09: Trying not to
SPEAKER_09: get
SPEAKER_09: common people involved with
SPEAKER_09: the gang war stuff, but
SPEAKER_09: you can only
SPEAKER_09: hope to keep
SPEAKER_09: your people safe, right?
UNKNOWN: Uh,
SPEAKER_09: anyway,
SPEAKER_09: uh, Mira, about the
SPEAKER_00: training grounds, you
SPEAKER_00: are fine. You can use them to your
Kakashi: liking, and, uh,
Kakashi: if you need and
Kakashi: require any help, we will send
Kakashi: down any people you want to.
Kakashi: Uh, Vodka
SPEAKER_00: will be joining you
SPEAKER_00: just in case you need anything.
Kakashi: So, be
Kakashi: nice to her.
Kakashi: Uh, you see the woman
Kakashi: like right, uh,
Kakashi: aside you, she just nods
Kakashi: and doesn't really say anything.
Kakashi: And, yeah, she
Kakashi: just like gets up
Kakashi: and is
SPEAKER_09: like ready to go or something.
UNKNOWN: Uh,
UNKNOWN: well,
Kakashi: Mira starts to speak up
Kakashi: and she goes, uh,
Kakashi: uh,
Kakashi: I didn't think it was a big deal.
Kakashi: You didn't have to call everyone, but
Kakashi: uh, I'm glad everyone
Kakashi: is aware that, uh, I
Kakashi: have some people over and
Kakashi: we're gonna be busy for a while.
Kakashi: In case you hear something back from
Kakashi: the other side, you let me
Kakashi: know, okay?
Kakashi: Uh, all of the people
Kakashi: alongside Mira, uh,
Kakashi: had, like, stand up and
Kakashi: start to move out. Uh,
Kakashi: do you guys wanna
Kakashi: talk with anyone or are you just, like, leaving
Kakashi: with Mira?
Baptiste: Is there anything to talk about right now?
Roma: I mean, it's up to you.
Roma: When they introduced themselves, Jack probably
Jack: had this, all of this phase of like,
Jack: well, this is interesting.
UNKNOWN: Yeah.
Roma: Yeah.
UNKNOWN: Uh,
Roma: Would you like to accompany us, Jin?
Roma: Wait, let me s-
UNKNOWN: give me a sec. Yeah, what would you say?
Baptiste: I'm just asking if Jin would like to accompany us.
Kakashi: Uh, okay, as you are heading out,
Kakashi: as Jin follows,
Kakashi: uh, behind you,
Kakashi: uh, you look
Kakashi: backward and start
Kakashi: talking to him, and you ask
Kakashi: him if he would like to
Kakashi: follow you?
SPEAKER_04: Yeah, to the training grounds.
Kakashi: Okay, uh,
Kakashi: you see Whiskey at this point
Kakashi: here, overhears your conversation, and she
Kakashi: goes,
Kakashi: that kid is busy with his own
Kakashi: little crew to be messing around
Kakashi: with more pirates, isn't he?
Kakashi: Uh,
Kakashi: Jin looks at Whiskey and he
Kakashi: says, you need to shut the fuck up
UNKNOWN: about that, okay? Don't let
Kakashi: anyone else find out.
Kakashi: I told you that in confidence.
UNKNOWN: Uh,
Kakashi: and he looks at you and he goes,
Kakashi: I'm good. And he
Kakashi: like, walks in front of you
Kakashi: and just, like, walks away.
Kakashi: Uh, the other people,
Kakashi: you see, uh, just, like, head into, like,
Kakashi: different part of, uh,
Kakashi: the tavern.
Kakashi: You see, like, they- they head into, like,
Kakashi: the- the living areas around here
Kakashi: that you can see, and,
Kakashi: uh, everyone, uh, clears
Kakashi: up and, uh, Whiskey
Kakashi: and, uh, Tequila,
Kakashi: the guy who you asked
Kakashi: to find stuff about Bramble,
Kakashi: uh, just, like, goes back
Kakashi: into his corner and starts drinking.
Kakashi: Uh, Mira
Kakashi: gets out and she goes, well, there
Kakashi: are some tables here at the
Kakashi: evening if you wanna give your luck a try.
Kakashi: Uh, I wouldn't, uh,
Kakashi: bet on it, though. Uh, pretty
Kakashi: rough. I lost a lot of money here,
Kakashi: unfortunately. Uh,
Kakashi: alright, follow me.
Baptiste: Does she mean that we're out or
Baptiste: late if I were to come later?
Kakashi: Uh,
Kakashi: around nighttime, 9 to 10
Kakashi: p.m. onwards,
Roma: it just keeps going.
Kakashi: Alright, uh, on your way, you can maybe
Kakashi: discuss anything you want, otherwise we'll just-
Jack: Yeah, well, I was gonna do one more thing before
Jack: I left the room. The-
Jack: I was- Go ahead.
Jack: Maybe, as the others,
Jack: like, Baptiste and Mira left, I was gonna turn around
Jack: and, like, give a-
Jack: a small bow, or, like, tip my
Jack: to the big boss and say,
Jack: we'll see you around.
Roma: We'll see you
Roma: around, too, strange
Roma: fella.
UNKNOWN: Uh,
Kakashi: and, uh, she
Kakashi: will lead you to the
Kakashi: outskirts of the town. At
Kakashi: first, uh, you're, like, moving towards,
Kakashi: uh, like, a
Kakashi: open plain area with, like, a bunch
Kakashi: of houses around, uh,
Kakashi: and you see a bunch of people in, like,
Kakashi: top hats and, like, suits walking
Kakashi: around on the town, uh,
Kakashi: around the town, uh,
Kakashi: kind of, like, talking to
Kakashi: a bunch of people, and it
Kakashi: mostly seems very peaceful to you.
Kakashi: Nothing seems out of sort.
Kakashi: Uh, as you walk through the town, the,
Kakashi: uh, like,
Kakashi: houses start to, like, die down, and
Kakashi: now you're walking into, like, plain
Kakashi: fields, uh, on, like,
Kakashi: an off-road, and
Kakashi: you climb, uh, uh,
Kakashi: like, some, uh,
Kakashi: plateaus, a little,
Kakashi: like, not, like, that big, like,
Kakashi: small, like, stairways
Kakashi: toward, like, open ground,
Kakashi: and at the end,
Kakashi: you all end up
Kakashi: at
Kakashi: the training grounds.
Baptiste: While we were walking,
Baptiste: I just wanted to
Baptiste: bring up the mirror
Baptiste: that
Baptiste: Linus and them are on
Baptiste: the island.
UNKNOWN: Just so
Baptiste: if we do run into them, she
Baptiste: isn't shocked by it, but also
Baptiste: to let her know that they're
Baptiste: trying not to associate with us
Roma: while we're on the island, just
Roma: to gather information.
Roma: And faster doctor got
Kakashi: away again. I swear
Kakashi: to God, once I get my hands
Kakashi: on him, I'm gonna pound him to the ground.
SPEAKER_07: Anyway, let's, let's keep going.
Kakashi: Uh, as you,
Kakashi: like, start climbing up toward
Kakashi: this end, Roma and,
Kakashi: uh, Trey
Kakashi: and, uh,
SPEAKER_07: Bob
UNKNOWN: and
SPEAKER_07: Cade, oh,
UNKNOWN: are already
SPEAKER_07: there. Uh,
SPEAKER_07: and let me bring
SPEAKER_07: Jack and
SPEAKER_07: Baptiste.
Kakashi: Okay, um,
Kakashi: while you guys are waiting
Kakashi: for Baptiste and,
Kakashi: uh, Jack to show up, what, what are
Kakashi: you guys doing in the meantime?
Roma: We training. We getting
SPEAKER_09: ready. Trey's not training.
SPEAKER_09: Trey's just here to bring you
SPEAKER_09: here, that's it. He's not doing nothing.
SPEAKER_09: You're
SPEAKER_09: training with who, Roma?
Roma: I have no idea, whoever
Roma: we're supposed to train with.
Kakashi: No, Trey brought you here
Kakashi: to, like, train with
Kakashi: Mira, uh, eventually
Kakashi: and the
Kakashi: rest of you can maybe
Kakashi: do something, I don't know.
Roma: Yeah, that don't matter to me.
Roma: I could just be, uh, hanging out.
Roma: Okay. You know,
Roma: relaxing. Okay.
UNKNOWN: Bob?
UNKNOWN: I would love to do anything except
UNKNOWN: training.
SPEAKER_09: Oh,
SPEAKER_09: hey, you know you agreed
SPEAKER_09: to come here, right? As long as I'm not forced.
Bob: As long, well, as long as I'm not
Bob: forced, like the later training sessions
Bob: with Mira and whatnot, I'm good.
Bob: Okay, okay.
SPEAKER_08: You know you agreed to this, by
SPEAKER_08: the way, right?
Roma: He's, he's smoking his bar.
UNKNOWN: Okay.
Roma: Mentally preparing himself.
Kakashi: Okay, cool, cool, cool, cool.
Kakashi: Uh, as Mira, like, guides
Kakashi: you all, uh,
Kakashi: toward, like, uh, the training
Kakashi: grounds. Oh, wait, Mira's here?
UNKNOWN: What? Yeah.
Kakashi: Yeah, that was the plan.
Kakashi: What do you mean? Oh, wait,
Bob: we're doing the training right now?
UNKNOWN: Yes! Yeah, Bob!
Bob: What the fuck? What the hell do you-
SPEAKER_08: Okay.
SPEAKER_08: You were just brought here to
SPEAKER_08: sightsee? That's what you thought the plan
SPEAKER_08: was?
UNKNOWN: Okay.
SPEAKER_09: Alright. It's called the training grounds
Roma: for a reason.
Roma: I told you we were going to the training grounds.
Bob: In my defense,
Bob: I was gone for fifteen
Bob: minutes to get my food order, so I
Kakashi: Oh, okay, okay. Cool, cool.
Bob: What do you think the whole session is about?
SPEAKER_08: Okay, yeah.
Baptiste: Okay. Uh, Bob
Baptiste: got here and genuinely did not
Baptiste: know we were about to try this. Yeah, yeah.
Kakashi: Yeah, let's just go with that.
Kakashi: As soon as you all get here, you
Kakashi: see, uh, Vodka
Kakashi: just kind of appear in front
Kakashi: of this pillar. His name's
Kakashi: Vodka? Her name is
Kakashi: Vodka. Her. Oh.
Roma: That's dope.
Kakashi: You did not hear any of the other names.
Roma: I did not.
Roma: I did not pay
Roma: attention! I pay attention, I just
Roma: didn't hear her name was actually
UNKNOWN: Vodka. All of the other
SPEAKER_09: names are also alcohols.
UNKNOWN: Rum,
SPEAKER_09: Rum,
SPEAKER_09: Gin, Whiskey,
SPEAKER_13: Whiskey, Vodka. I heard Gin and Whiskey.
UNKNOWN: Tequila, Brandy.
Roma: I wasn't putting, I wasn't putting
Roma: two and two together. I see, I see,
Kakashi: I see. Cool.
Kakashi: Uh, so, she just like,
Kakashi: uh, overlooking
Kakashi: everything, and
Kakashi: uh,
Kakashi: Mira takes, like, the
Kakashi: center stage, and
Kakashi: she calls in
Kakashi: Trey,
Kakashi: uh, towards her.
Kakashi: Trey, like,
Kakashi: sighs, and just walks up to her.
Kakashi: And, uh,
Kakashi: she asks all of you to, like,
Kakashi: um, like,
Kakashi: uh, pay attention at this point.
UNKNOWN: Alright.
Kakashi: Now, I am aware
Kakashi: that you have been
Kakashi: in,
Kakashi: uh, some struggle lately.
Kakashi: Uh, I don't know about you,
Kakashi: Jack, but
Kakashi: I suppose you've seen
Kakashi: some fair share of,
UNKNOWN: um,
Kakashi: conflict with these
UNKNOWN: guys.
Kakashi: Um, anyway,
UNKNOWN: so, let me
UNKNOWN: shh,
Kakashi: I think you're basically
Kakashi: aware of these concepts, but
Kakashi: I don't think you've actually
Kakashi: practiced them that much.
Kakashi: Uh,
Kakashi: the upcoming
Kakashi: fight, if there
Kakashi: will be a fight, is not
Kakashi: going to be easy.
Kakashi: Because there's
Kakashi: gonna be a lot of people involved, a lot of
Kakashi: commotion and
Kakashi: everything. Everyone has to fend for
Kakashi: themselves.
Kakashi: So I'm expecting everyone to
Kakashi: hold their own.
Kakashi: This is war.
Kakashi: War does not allow
Kakashi: for fairness
Kakashi: or any
Kakashi: of the other
Kakashi: complexities.
Kakashi: We're pirates. We're used to
Kakashi: fighting sea battles,
Kakashi: but
Kakashi: a battle on land and on this
Kakashi: scale is
Kakashi: difficult.
Kakashi: And, uh,
Kakashi: fortunately, none of you have
Kakashi: mastered
Kakashi: hockey, I'm assuming.
UNKNOWN: But
Kakashi: the next
Kakashi: few days,
Kakashi: weeks, or months, whatever it is,
Kakashi: going to be
Kakashi: is you getting
Kakashi: drilled day in
Kakashi: and day out
Kakashi: until you show me
Kakashi: one form
Kakashi: of hockey. Intentional,
Kakashi: non-intentional,
Kakashi: is not acceptable anymore.
Kakashi: You have to control it.
Kakashi: You have to wield it.
Kakashi: And that is
Kakashi: where I will leave you alone.
Kakashi: After that, you can train
Kakashi: by yourself.
Kakashi: Now, uh,
Kakashi: Baptiste, I don't think you know
Kakashi: this, but our
Kakashi: deckhand over here,
Kakashi: Trey, has gotten
Kakashi: himself a very useful
Kakashi: fruit. Don't you,
Kakashi: Trey?
Kakashi: Uh, let me
Kakashi: give you a demonstration.
Kakashi: Uh, she
Kakashi: like, winds up
Kakashi: one of her punches and just hits
Kakashi: Trey right in the space.
Kakashi: He, like, flies in, and
Kakashi: lands on, like, a corner.
Kakashi: And he, like,
Kakashi: just gets up. He doesn't
Kakashi: seem injured at all.
Kakashi: He starts walking towards
Kakashi: Mira, and he's
Kakashi: like, ta-da!
Kakashi: And she
Kakashi: goes, so, Trey has
Kakashi: the Forsfroach
Kakashi: fruit, which,
Kakashi: uh, incidentally,
Kakashi: lets, uh,
Kakashi: any injury heal
Kakashi: instantly.
Kakashi: So, every time
Kakashi: you get beaten to a pulp,
Kakashi: Trey will fix
Kakashi: you up, and you will start training
UNKNOWN: again. Is there any confusion?
SPEAKER_04: Did he find this fruit, or did you give him
SPEAKER_04: this fruit?
Kakashi: Oh, uh, fortunate
Kakashi: enough, you know how these
Kakashi: devil's fruits work out. Trey
Kakashi: find the, well, we found the
Kakashi: fruit, Trey ate it. That's a different thing.
Kakashi: Uh,
UNKNOWN: but,
Kakashi: at least, he's
Kakashi: uh, able to wield it
Kakashi: a bit better now.
Baptiste: I wanna look at Trey.
Baptiste: Yeah. And see what his eyes are telling me.
Kakashi: His eyes
Kakashi: are, he's, like, behind Mira, so
Kakashi: he's just signaling you
Kakashi: to, like, cut it, don't ask
Kakashi: further, don't ask further.
SPEAKER_08: Uh, he's like,
SPEAKER_08: Trey?
SPEAKER_08: She's looking back, and he's just, like,
SPEAKER_08: stiffens up, and he's like,
SPEAKER_08: aye aye, Captain!
UNKNOWN: So, Captain of the Lunarfold
Kakashi: Pirates, would you like to step in
Kakashi: to
Kakashi: maybe cheer on
Kakashi: and give your
Kakashi: fellow crewmates
UNKNOWN: uh,
UNKNOWN: some preview
Kakashi: to their training?
Baptiste: I'm gonna have to do it eventually.
UNKNOWN: Alright.
Kakashi: Uh,
Kakashi: Alright, so, I'm gonna put you
Kakashi: and her into, uh,
Kakashi: combat.
Kakashi: Mira's strong suit is not
Kakashi: holding back, so I will not be holding
Kakashi: back.
Roma: Uh, you just
Kakashi: try to, uh,
Kakashi: stay alive as long
Kakashi: as you can, and I'll count the
UNKNOWN: rounds. At 20, let's
Kakashi: go! Uh,
UNKNOWN: Nice. What the
Kakashi: fuck is happening? I don't know.
Baptiste: I'm gonna have to combat.
Kakashi: Yeah. Alright,
Kakashi: Baptiste, let's get ready.
Bob: 3-9-20
Bob: is a good omen.
SPEAKER_07: Yeah, it is a good omen. Let me see.
SPEAKER_07: Uh, let me get some battle
UNKNOWN: music going. Okay.
UNKNOWN: Okay.
UNKNOWN: Okay?
Roma: Okay.
Roma: Uh, can you guys hear the
UNKNOWN: music? Just
Jack: bucka-chocka-chock? Yeah.
UNKNOWN: Uh,
Kakashi: alright, as the
Kakashi: battle starts,
UNKNOWN: Baptiste, it's your
Kakashi: turn to go.
Baptiste: Yep, I'm
Baptiste: starting off with
Baptiste: setting up.
UNKNOWN: Alright, let's go. That's a good start.
Baptiste: Activate my haste, and then
UNKNOWN: also activate
Baptiste: my flame duality, and we're going
Baptiste: ignited.
UNKNOWN: Alright.
Baptiste: That's an action and
Baptiste: a bonus. Then the
Baptiste: haste action...
UNKNOWN: Wait.
UNKNOWN: Can only be used to attack, dash,
Baptiste: disengage, hide.
Baptiste: I can't hide.
Bob: Wait, it cannot use to be...
Bob: Can't it be used to take the dodge
UNKNOWN: action? No.
Bob: Ah, goddamn.
Baptiste: If only.
Baptiste: Wait, can I use dodge?
Baptiste: It's not listed, but it's...
Kakashi: Yeah, you can, you can.
Baptiste: Oh, I'll dodge.
UNKNOWN: Alright.
Jack: It says that you can use it to dash, disengage,
UNKNOWN: or hide, or use
UNKNOWN: an object. You can't, then?
Jack: Or utilize action.
Jack: Yeah, utilize action.
UNKNOWN: Yeah. This action can be
Jack: used to take one attack, dash, disengage,
Jack: hide, or use an object.
Kakashi: Yeah, you can use one attack, then.
Jack: Yeah, but not dodge.
Kakashi: Yeah, you can dodge.
Jack: Going in.
UNKNOWN: Alright.
Baptiste: Let's test the waters.
Baptiste: Why am I attacking myself?
UNKNOWN: Stop hitting yourself.
Baptiste: Stop hitting yourself.
Kakashi: As you, like,
Kakashi: burst in with your first
Kakashi: punch,
Kakashi: you just go straight through, Mira.
Kakashi: As her body
Kakashi: like, fades into the air,
Kakashi: she forms back
Kakashi: right behind you.
Kakashi: As the air twirls around.
UNKNOWN: Oh, I was gonna move.
Baptiste: That's fine.
Kakashi: Uh...
Kakashi: She, like, forms back.
Kakashi: Do you have anything else?
Baptiste: Nope, that's everything.
Kakashi: Alright.
Roma: Wouldn't that technically...
UNKNOWN: I do not have sentiment.
Bob: Roma, you have
UNKNOWN: sentiment. Yeah, but I thought he
UNKNOWN: did, too. I opted out of
Baptiste: getting...
UNKNOWN: for the time being. Okay.
Kakashi: She's gonna prepare to
UNKNOWN: which is...
SPEAKER_08: First, it's
SPEAKER_08: going to be...
SPEAKER_07: Uh, where is it?
Kakashi: Forms...
Kakashi: Uh, so...
Kakashi: She uses
Kakashi: Fishman Kung Fu, like a
Kakashi: different form of Fishman Karate.
Kakashi: She can, on every
Kakashi: one of her, like, unarmed
Kakashi: strikes, she can either
Kakashi: push you back, knock you prone,
Kakashi: deal an extra 1d8 damage,
Kakashi: uh, and
Kakashi: that's about it. After
Kakashi: that, she can
Kakashi: use bonus
Kakashi: one-step.
Kakashi: So, the next attack,
Kakashi: which is now, she's going to
UNKNOWN: hit you
UNKNOWN: with
Kakashi: the Brick Fist.
UNKNOWN: There you go.
UNKNOWN: Uh,
Kakashi: she's going to make four unarmed
Kakashi: strikes, so
Kakashi: get ready for that. All of them will be
Kakashi: Haki-infused.
Kakashi: So, if you don't die on the first one,
Kakashi: or knock out on the first one, I'll be very
Kakashi: uh,
Kakashi: impressed, honestly.
Bob: Uh, the eight
Bob: forms? Yes, yes.
Kakashi: Oh, yeah, yeah, yeah, the first one, the first one, then.
UNKNOWN: Oh, okay.
Kakashi: Uh...
UNKNOWN: Good reading, Bob. Where is
Kakashi: her...
Kakashi: Where the fuck is her... Oh, God.
Kakashi: Did I not actually make
Kakashi: a single fucking
SPEAKER_07: attack?
SPEAKER_07: Attach fence...
UNKNOWN: I actually don't have attack attached to this,
SPEAKER_08: God damn it.
SPEAKER_08: Uh, let me check
Kakashi: Tom's
SPEAKER_04: sheet, I think.
UNKNOWN: Bro,
Kakashi: I, uh, I forgot.
Kakashi: I swear to God, I
Kakashi: made, like,
Kakashi: attack
Kakashi: items on this? Did they just
UNKNOWN: delete it? Oh, no, no,
Kakashi: it is, okay, it's in weapons for some reason.
Kakashi: Yeah, there we go.
Kakashi: Uh, so every
Kakashi: hit, you see Mira, like,
Kakashi: kind of, like, uh,
Kakashi: pulls all the wind
Kakashi: around her into the punch as
Kakashi: she strikes with every punch, and
Kakashi: her, like, body, uh,
Kakashi: posture is in, like, in
Kakashi: some form of, like, stance
Kakashi: as each attack hits you.
Kakashi: The first attack she hits
Kakashi: you will just straight up, like,
Kakashi: push you 15 feet
Kakashi: back.
Kakashi: Let's see if it hits first.
Kakashi: 16. Won't hit, right? No.
Kakashi: Okay. As the first,
Kakashi: like, uh, no,
Kakashi: that's plus 2, 18. 18 will not hit
Kakashi: still, right? No.
Kakashi: Okay. As the
Kakashi: first blow just
Kakashi: whizzes past you with the sheer
UNKNOWN: force, I'm gonna do
UNKNOWN: another one. She's
Kakashi: rolling very bad. It's the same.
UNKNOWN: Alright, this is gonna hit.
UNKNOWN: 25. No.
Kakashi: What do you mean 25?
Kakashi: That doesn't hit.
Baptiste: Just no.
Baptiste: I'm glad.
Kakashi: Uh, alright, the first hit
Kakashi: just lands you straight on
Kakashi: this rock, uh,
Kakashi: as that will
Kakashi: finish you for
Kakashi: 27 full because it's Haki
Kakashi: infused.
Kakashi: And then one more hit.
Kakashi: Let's see if you pass out in the second one
UNKNOWN: or not. I feel like I
Baptiste: lost, like, my odds.
Kakashi: 25.
Kakashi: 36. 36 and 27
Kakashi: is game over, right?
UNKNOWN: Alright. Do you wanna
Kakashi: do anything? You can shield
Kakashi: or maybe try something else.
Baptiste: I can't shield because I used all
Baptiste: my points. Oh, you used all your
Kakashi: points, yeah.
Kakashi: Alright, so, uh,
Kakashi: as you, like, fly in with one
Kakashi: of your fists, Mira just disappears from
Kakashi: in front of you, forms back,
Kakashi: hits, like, uh,
Kakashi: just as, like, an intimidation tactic,
Kakashi: just, like, uh,
Kakashi: throws one fist with just,
Kakashi: like, air. Uh,
Kakashi: the second fist
Kakashi: also misses, but the
Kakashi: last two just throw you into
Kakashi: that rock as you
Kakashi: just fall unconscious.
Kakashi: Uh, so close.
Kakashi: Mira turns around
Kakashi: and
Kakashi: goes, okay,
UNKNOWN: who's next? Bob's gonna go
Bob: well, I guess. Alright.
Bob: Also, out of character because I probably
Bob: have to leave soon, so I wanna get my
Bob: thing done quickly so that you guys can continue without me.
SPEAKER_08: Yeah, yeah, yeah. Roll.
SPEAKER_08: Roll for initiative. I don't really have to roll, though,
Bob: because I have minus one for initiative.
Bob: It's not, like, a... Okay.
Kakashi: As soon as you say that,
Kakashi: uh,
SPEAKER_07: she's just gonna
UNKNOWN: still wanna do it.
Bob: Fly.
SPEAKER_07: 16, okay. Uh,
Kakashi: she's gonna start with
Kakashi: another, uh,
Kakashi: strike.
Kakashi: Strike.
Kakashi: And this time she's just gonna, like,
Kakashi: burst in
Kakashi: and just, like, uh,
Kakashi: form, like, a palm from her fist
Kakashi: and just, like, shove, uh,
Kakashi: her fist, like, straight into
Kakashi: your stomach.
Kakashi: Can you make a deck save, please?
UNKNOWN: Sure.
Bob: I most likely will.
Bob: Uh, semi-super quick.
Kakashi: Oh my god.
SPEAKER_08: Oh my god. You've been rolling very bad
SPEAKER_08: and Baptiste has been rolling
SPEAKER_08: very good. I don't know what's happening.
Kakashi: Uh, alright.
Kakashi: With a single strike, she just
Kakashi: smacks you on your stomach as you keep
Kakashi: fly back, like, 15
Kakashi: feet again and just pass out.
Kakashi: Uh...
Bob: Alright.
UNKNOWN: I mean, it's
Kakashi: 10 to 10, man.
Kakashi: What do you mean?
Bob: I mean, I still wanna take a chance.
SPEAKER_07: Okay, sure.
Bob: That's 56.
Kakashi: You're not knocked out?
Bob: No, I'm not.
Kakashi: Alright, you, uh...
Bob: So, uh, DM, another question.
Bob: What kind of damage is it?
Kakashi: It's bludgeoning.
Kakashi: What kind of damage? Haki-infused.
Kakashi: Nothing you do will be able to...
Roma: Okay, okay. Yeah.
Kakashi: We'll be able to withstand it.
Kakashi: Unless you have, like, armament
Kakashi: Haki, which you don't already have.
Kakashi: No, no, no.
Kakashi: Uh, so, the...
Kakashi: What did I do?
Kakashi: Plus two damage.
Baptiste: What?
Baptiste: Plus two damage.
Kakashi: Uh...
Kakashi: No, I think the rules
Kakashi: are different here.
Kakashi: Let me check.
Kakashi: It's still not gonna knock him out.
Kakashi: That's fine. It's fine. She has another
Kakashi: attack.
Bob: Can you, like, do the damage for me?
Bob: Because one of my hands...
Bob: Yeah, that's fine.
Kakashi: Fly ass damage.
UNKNOWN: Alright.
Kakashi: Next is she's going to...
Kakashi: Tempest throw.
UNKNOWN: And
Kakashi: throw you back down to...
Kakashi: Uh...
UNKNOWN: Uh...
Kakashi: Which is I'm gonna grapple you.
Kakashi: You can resist the grapple with
Kakashi: acrobatics or athletics.
UNKNOWN: 24.
UNKNOWN: Okay.
Kakashi: You're just rolling, Batman.
Kakashi: Just rolling, Batman. I don't know what to do.
Kakashi: Uh, she grabs
Kakashi: you as soon as you, like,
Kakashi: land on the ground. You just can't even
Kakashi: get the time to look
Kakashi: up. Before then, she
Kakashi: just grabs your neck and throws you back.
Kakashi: And you
Kakashi: land back into
Kakashi: the training grounds.
UNKNOWN: And
Kakashi: you're gonna take another
SPEAKER_07: 4d10 damage.
Bob: Am I getting
Bob: the damage from...
Bob: Do the damage first. I'm probably out, but...
Bob: Yeah, I'm out.
Bob: Oh, no, no. Wait, wait, wait.
Bob: I wanna push this.
Bob: Am I taking the damage from
Bob: colliding with the ground?
UNKNOWN: Yes.
Kakashi: Because this was not
Kakashi: Haki infused. No, no.
UNKNOWN: And I have a
Bob: resistance to bludgeoning damage.
Bob: So that'll be 9. I'm still at 1 HP.
UNKNOWN: Okay.
SPEAKER_08: You're really pushing this.
Kakashi: As
Kakashi: you fall
Kakashi: down, you still try to get
Kakashi: up. Mira
Kakashi: pushes back, and she still sees
Kakashi: you up. And she goes,
UNKNOWN: You're still
Kakashi: up. I'm impressed.
UNKNOWN: Alright.
UNKNOWN: Come at me. She's like
Kakashi: just jumping around on her feet.
UNKNOWN: Alright.
Kakashi: It's your turn.
Bob: Okay.
UNKNOWN: Can you add 25?
Kakashi: Oh, you can't add it? I'm sorry.
Kakashi: 26.
UNKNOWN: Thank you.
Bob: Do I have any
Bob: bonus action? I don't really think
Bob: any of my stuff will do
Bob: anything.
SPEAKER_08: That's the point of the training.
Bob: Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Bob: None of these are gonna do shit.
Bob: Yup. That's
Bob: the end of my turn.
Bob: Oh, wait. What's this?
Bob: No, it doesn't do shit.
UNKNOWN: Alright.
Bob: Wait, wait, wait. No, no. DM, DM, DM.
Bob: It does do an ability check.
Bob: Yeah, yeah. Let me, let me just
Bob: Alright.
UNKNOWN: So,
Bob: so bonus action, hex on her,
Bob: and by hex, he just, Bob just
Bob: breathes a mist
Bob: of toxic fume on her, and that
Bob: just, like, kind of bothers
Bob: her, but it's a test, and her
Bob: ability checks are, like,
Bob: disadvantage. Okay.
Kakashi: Alright.
Kakashi: As you, like, get
Kakashi: up, and like,
Kakashi: kind of smoke into her face,
Kakashi: she, like, waves it away
Kakashi: with her Logia,
Kakashi: and she
Kakashi: is going to
Kakashi: attack you with the Flurry of Blows
UNKNOWN: next, and
Kakashi: let's see.
UNKNOWN: Ow. That's a crit.
Bob: Well, then, that, okay,
Bob: we don't have to do anything else.
Bob: Oh, no, she's fucking you up. You hit her, bro.
Roma: As soon as
Kakashi: she, as soon as she, like,
Kakashi: gets, like, a whiff of
Kakashi: that, she just, like,
Kakashi: puts her fist, and just, like, straight
Kakashi: up, like, hits you in the back, and
Kakashi: like, lays you down.
Kakashi: You're also unconscious.
Kakashi: Ow. Trey, at
Kakashi: this point, just grabs you, and
Kakashi: pulls you aside.
Kakashi: Alright, who's next?
Jack: Can you, oh,
Jack: nevermind.
UNKNOWN: I will never
Jack: join again.
Kakashi: You're not able to join again?
Jack: No, I'm, I had to reload, and then
Jack: I was able to now, uh,
Jack: loading, I think.
Jack: Uh,
Kakashi: alright, Roma,
Kakashi: come on in. Okay, can you
Kakashi: roll for initiative?
Kakashi: Uh, there you go.
UNKNOWN: Kill him.
SPEAKER_07: Oh my god. Oh my god.
SPEAKER_08: You're gonna die,
UNKNOWN: man. One hit.
UNKNOWN: Uh, alright, she
Kakashi: is
Kakashi: going to
UNKNOWN: pick back up for this.
Kakashi: yeah, Trey at this point
Kakashi: has, like, you see, like,
Kakashi: uh, as you open your eyes,
Kakashi: you see Trey's kind of, like, punching into
Kakashi: you with, like, small hits,
Kakashi: as you see, like, bang, bang,
Kakashi: like, metal hitting
Kakashi: sounds on your body, as
Kakashi: you wake up, and, like, every, like,
Kakashi: broken bone in your body gets just
Kakashi: fixed, uh, and
Kakashi: you're back up. Uh,
Kakashi: and then he starts working on
Kakashi: um, Bob
Kakashi: again. Uh,
Kakashi: alright, um,
Kakashi: uh, Roma,
Kakashi: she, at this point, will start
Kakashi: using her Logia, and you can
Kakashi: see her body, like, floating above
Kakashi: the ground, and
Kakashi: she is going to, again, grab you,
Kakashi: and throw you onto the ground.
Kakashi: Uh, Tempest
Kakashi: Throw, uh, you can do either
Kakashi: Acrobatics or Athletics checks,
UNKNOWN: whichever you want. She's going to do
UNKNOWN: a Strength check. Now, it's not,
Kakashi: uh, that high. You can maybe get out of this.
Kakashi: No. No, you can't get out of this.
Kakashi: Uh, alright.
Kakashi: She, again, grabs
Kakashi: you by your, like, foot,
Kakashi: and she's just gonna chuck you in the
Kakashi: sky, as she
Kakashi: expan- uh, like, uh, bashes
Kakashi: you back onto the ground, and
Kakashi: that will be
SPEAKER_07: 4d... what was it?
SPEAKER_07: 4d10.
Roma: 4d10, no matter what, I'm still alive.
Roma: I get one attack. Uh, 15.
Kakashi: Yeah, but that's her, like,
Kakashi: one action. That second action is gonna
UNKNOWN: be, uh,
Kakashi: let's do the Stunning Strike
Kakashi: with the next one.
Kakashi: Uh,
Kakashi: alright, she's gonna just, like,
Kakashi: come down with, like, full speed,
Kakashi: and hit you straight in the head.
Kakashi: Uh, 18.
Kakashi: That hits.
Kakashi: Normal.
Kakashi: 27.
Kakashi: And that's gonna be, uh,
Kakashi: wait, is that it?
Roma: Yeah, you said
Roma: 27 and 15.
UNKNOWN: Oh.
Kakashi: 15 is only there, huh?
Kakashi: Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Kakashi: 42. Yeah. Just 42.
Kakashi: Uh, which is
Kakashi: 11, but that's gonna be a
Kakashi: Stunning Strike.
Kakashi: So, can you make a...
Kakashi: deck save?
Kakashi: No, it's a con save, right?
Kakashi: Yeah, con save, sorry.
Kakashi: What's your con modifier? We'll just add it
UNKNOWN: to this one. 11.
Kakashi: 11 plus 6.
Kakashi: That's 17. Yeah, that's
Kakashi: still not enough.
Kakashi: Uh, okay. You are
Kakashi: stunned, and as soon as you
Kakashi: get stunned, she hits you again,
Kakashi: uh, right in your face, landing you
Kakashi: on, uh, your back.
Kakashi: Uh,
Kakashi: that's gonna be with advantage, so it's not,
Kakashi: like, there's no point of me rolling, but
Kakashi: I'll just roll once again.
Kakashi: 30. Okay.
Kakashi: Uh, as soon as you
Kakashi: knock out, Trey will grab you
Kakashi: and start healing you.
Kakashi: Uh, and
Kakashi: she is going to
Kakashi: go... Alright, the next two can
Kakashi: come at once.
UNKNOWN: Oh, don't worry, Trey's got
Baptiste: this.
SPEAKER_08: What do you mean, Trey's got this,
UNKNOWN: Cayde? Trey's
Jack: got this.
Jack: Trey's got it.
UNKNOWN: Okay.
Kakashi: You can, you can be far, that's fine.
Kakashi: It's fine. You don't need to come close yet.
UNKNOWN: Yeah.
UNKNOWN: Uh,
Kakashi: let me move you here.
Kakashi: Okay, Cayde, Baptiste,
Kakashi: go ahead.
UNKNOWN: Yep.
Kakashi: Alright, let's see who's first. Jack?
UNKNOWN: And
Kakashi: Cayde, both are first.
UNKNOWN: I guess I'm
Jack: just gonna shoot.
UNKNOWN: Not shoot?
UNKNOWN: Yeah, take.
Kakashi: Okay, go straight through her.
UNKNOWN: Let's see.
Kakashi: Uh, it's gonna hit
Kakashi: right, like, right behind
Kakashi: you, the shot,
Kakashi: Baptiste. The second
Kakashi: one will hit.
UNKNOWN: Yay. Wait.
Jack: The one becomes
UNKNOWN: an eight, so it's 18
UNKNOWN: damage. Uh, what one becomes an eight?
Kakashi: Oh, the failed one?
Jack: I see.
Jack: Because I can reroll.
Jack: Once per turn, I can reroll a die.
Jack: Well, not reroll, but take the opposite side of
UNKNOWN: the dice. Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Kakashi: Uh, nine
Kakashi: applies damage.
Kakashi: Okay, as, like, one of the bullets
Kakashi: kind of, like, take her by surprise, she
Kakashi: catches it, uh, and
Kakashi: just drops it on the ground.
Kakashi: Uh,
Kakashi: is that it?
Jack: I don't have bonus action, so that's it.
Kakashi: Okay, Cayde?
UNKNOWN: Yeah.
Baptiste: Go, Cayde.
Baptiste: Um,
Baptiste: I'm trying to remember.
Baptiste: Okay.
SPEAKER_07: Nice.
UNKNOWN: That was his action,
Baptiste: so.
Jack: Oh, yeah, that was an action.
Kakashi: I thought wild
Kakashi: shape is bonus. No, no,
Jack: Moon, for Moon drew it to this.
UNKNOWN: Oh.
Jack: Oh, well. But for everyone else, it's an action.
Baptiste: But we did say he keeps his
UNKNOWN: spells because he's
Baptiste: not actually transforming into an animal.
Kakashi: Yeah, I feel like, yeah,
Kakashi: it's not fair.
Kakashi: He's just, like, putting on a mask. I don't want
SPEAKER_08: it to be, like, a whole-ass action.
SPEAKER_05: I just have to transfer it over.
UNKNOWN: That's fine, that's fine.
SPEAKER_05: Because it always...
SPEAKER_05: But...
SPEAKER_05: Then he's just gonna activate his...
Kakashi: Vampire claws?
UNKNOWN: Yeah.
UNKNOWN: Alright. That's his turn.
UNKNOWN: Okay.
Kakashi: Uh, Mira looks at both of
Kakashi: you, and she
Kakashi: immediately knows that the first
Kakashi: one she needs to take care of is
Kakashi: Jack.
Kakashi: So...
Kakashi: So she's gonna winch step,
Kakashi: and the next attack
Kakashi: roll is gonna be
Kakashi: with advantage.
Kakashi: And, again,
Kakashi: her style
Kakashi: is more of
SPEAKER_08: destruction, so she's
SPEAKER_08: gonna grab you and throw you
UNKNOWN: around. Okay.
Kakashi: It's not bad. That's not bad to beat.
Kakashi: Acrobatics or athletics?
Jack: Oh, oh, I thought it was
Jack: an attack roll.
UNKNOWN: No.
Jack: Acrobatics.
Jack: My acrobatics is already a plus eight, so...
Kakashi: Nice. So,
Kakashi: uh, as soon as
Kakashi: she rushes in,
Kakashi: uh, you, uh,
Kakashi: just, like, climb onto
Kakashi: this pillar and
Kakashi: just leap off.
Kakashi: She will... Yeah, just do a dodge roll.
Kakashi: Yeah, just dodge roll like
Kakashi: the boss.
Kakashi: Uh, and
Kakashi: at this point she's gonna...
Kakashi: Uh...
UNKNOWN: Little roll, again.
Kakashi: Fid.
UNKNOWN: Her stunning
Kakashi: strike.
Kakashi: Actually, let's go flurry blows.
Jack: Oh, great. Yeah, sure.
Kakashi: You're a crafty bastard.
Kakashi: You might get away. Twenty.
Kakashi: Uh, and...
Kakashi: It's gonna be nineteen.
UNKNOWN: And then
Kakashi: one more.
UNKNOWN: She fails.
Kakashi: And it's gonna be...
Kakashi: Her turn.
Kakashi: Alright, Kate, uh,
Kakashi: you again. Jack. Yeah.
Jack: Uh, so, first
Jack: of all, let me get the fuck away from her.
Jack: Uh, where is this? No opportunity
Kakashi: stuff, right?
Jack: No.
UNKNOWN: Oh, that's an eight!
Kakashi: What's an eight?
UNKNOWN: The dice.
Jack: Uh, wait, let me turn in chat. Distinguish...
Kakashi: Yeah, yeah, sure, then chat so I know
Kakashi: what it's, uh... Play chat.
Jack: Run and flee.
Kakashi: Okay, nice.
Jack: Uh, that was an eight, so that's
Jack: forty. Forty feet.
UNKNOWN: Uh, goodbye.
Kakashi: I'll say forty feet is here.
Kakashi: Let's say forty feet is here, so I don't
Kakashi: want you getting too far away.
Kakashi: But I'll move
Kakashi: according to that. That's fine.
Jack: Well, that was forty feet where I am now.
Kakashi: No, I know, I know, but
Kakashi: I can't, like, logically I can't
Kakashi: make it that far.
Kakashi: You know what, I'll maybe increase
Kakashi: the map. Just give me one sec.
SPEAKER_07: Uh, let's do
SPEAKER_07: thirty. Then I
SPEAKER_07: think you will be able to, yeah.
UNKNOWN: Let's see. Uh, yeah, that's
SPEAKER_07: forty. Okay.
Kakashi: Uh, alright, now
Kakashi: she...
Kakashi: That was my bonus action. I still have some action.
UNKNOWN: Go ahead.
Jack: I can still shoot at her.
SPEAKER_08: Go ahead.
Jack: Yeah, I will.
SPEAKER_08: You're the first one to damage
SPEAKER_08: her, so that's good.
SPEAKER_08: Yippee!
Kakashi: Uh, twenty?
UNKNOWN: Hit?
Kakashi: Uh, no, it doesn't hit, I think.
UNKNOWN: Let me check. Uh, my
Kakashi: default...
UNKNOWN: Okay.
Kakashi: Uh, yeah, twenty doesn't hit.
Jack: Take
Jack: another one.
Kakashi: Okay.
Jack: Rawr!
Kakashi: I'll say you were close enough. You can move.
Kakashi: You can move.
SPEAKER_08: Twenty-four?! It actually hits!
UNKNOWN: Come on, Kade!
Jack: Kade and Jack, new tech team.
SPEAKER_08: Max
SPEAKER_08: damage? What the
SPEAKER_08: fuck?
Baptiste: For his... Oh,
Baptiste: and he gets his...
UNKNOWN: What's his spell?
Baptiste: Something?
Baptiste: He gets four
Baptiste: temp HP because
Baptiste: of his healing calls.
UNKNOWN: Uh,
Kakashi: as, like, Kade
Kakashi: kind of scratches her through the...
Kakashi: Uh, claws. She, like,
Kakashi: uh, sees, like, a bit of blood
Kakashi: on her, like,
Kakashi: forearm. And...
Kakashi: Uh...
Kakashi: Okay, I can...
SPEAKER_07: One more. I can't open her sheet
SPEAKER_07: for some reason.
Roma: Reloaded the page because they couldn't open me
Roma: her sheet for some reason.
UNKNOWN: She takes five
Roma: more damage.
UNKNOWN: I don't think he has any other bonus
UNKNOWN: effects. Well, that's a bonus, but he
Baptiste: doesn't need that right now.
Baptiste: Huh. Yeah, but...
Baptiste: Kade's turn.
Kakashi: Alright. Uh...
Kakashi: Mira, at this point, will
Kakashi: flatten
Kakashi: him first. Kade
Kakashi: first. Gonna make a deck save.
Kakashi: Again, like, a
Kakashi: palm straight through his stomach.
UNKNOWN: Okay.
Kakashi: You just hear, like, a resounding boom.
Kakashi: And... Kade
Kakashi: just, like, froths at the mouth
Kakashi: and just drops down.
UNKNOWN: Uh, next, she's gonna just burst.
Kakashi: 30 feet.
Kakashi: 45 feet, whatever.
Kakashi: And she's gonna...
Kakashi: Again, try to grab you.
UNKNOWN: He did damage.
Kakashi: He did damage. Honestly, that's...
Kakashi: That's pretty good.
Kakashi: Oh, nice.
Kakashi: Again, you... Again,
Kakashi: dog rolled right
Kakashi: behind her. Uh...
Kakashi: Alright. It's gonna be...
Kakashi: her turn.
Roma: Wasn't that her turn? She moved
UNKNOWN: and tried to grab? Yeah, that was her turn. Yeah, yeah.
UNKNOWN: That's her turn. I said that's her
UNKNOWN: turn. Uh...
Jack: Yeah, let's...
Jack: First off, get a bit away from her.
UNKNOWN: Alright.
Jack: That's a 7.
Jack: 35 feet. 35 feet.
Jack: Somewhere over here.
UNKNOWN: Alright. Shoot.
Jack: Uh, yeah.
UNKNOWN: Just shoot her. Hits.
Jack: Let's go.
UNKNOWN: Hmm.
Jack: Let's do the fun thing.
Jack: The one thing my subclass does.
Jack: Let's do this for the first time.
Jack: Let's have two privates.
Jack: Blind GM roll, I guess?
UNKNOWN: Yeah. No, I think I
SPEAKER_07: see it...
SPEAKER_07: Oh, that's the damage.
Kakashi: That's the damage.
Jack: You saw the damage? Yeah.
Kakashi: I think you have to...
Kakashi: You have to
Kakashi: roll the attack.
Kakashi: Roll the attack again, and then I think
Kakashi: roll it. Then that's when I don't see it.
Kakashi: Maybe.
Jack: Yeah, I'll do a self-roll. Maybe that doesn't
Kakashi: show... Yeah, yeah. Self-roll. Self-roll.
Jack: Uh, let's just
Jack: do a random... Do...
Kakashi: Do the damage, I guess.
SPEAKER_07: I still see it. Yeah.
UNKNOWN: Got damage. Blind GM roll, maybe?
Kakashi: Did you private GM
Kakashi: roll first?
Jack: Uh... You know what?
UNKNOWN: Do you have dice
Kakashi: in your house?
Kakashi: I don't know.
Jack: Let me... Just roll...
UNKNOWN: Yeah.
Jack: Send a picture. Yeah.
Jack: Do you have a pair of d8s?
Jack: Fuck, I only have one pair of my d8s with me.
Jack: Let me roll D&D Beyond.
Kakashi: Yeah, yeah. Rollin' D&D
Kakashi: Beyond, just let me know.
Kakashi: After.
UNKNOWN: Yeah. Uh...
Jack: Wait, I just have to
UNKNOWN: sub first. Uh, what was the thing
Kakashi: called? Let me take a look
Jack: at it. Let me display it in...
Jack: Play in chat.
UNKNOWN: Okay.
UNKNOWN: Got it. Uh, give me two seconds to
Jack: sub in D&D Beyond first.
Jack: Uh...
UNKNOWN: Sorry.
Jack: D&D Beyond wants to load.
UNKNOWN: Uh... Uh, so,
UNKNOWN: now, read the description
Jack: first to see if I do it correctly. Yeah, yeah.
Kakashi: Uh, what's the damage?
UNKNOWN: Uh, the damage is 10.
UNKNOWN: Okay.
Kakashi: Uh, so half of that, right?
Jack: Well, no. You need to
Jack: say either I thought it was... No, no.
Kakashi: Either... I'm not calling your bluff.
UNKNOWN: Alright.
Jack: Doesn't call your
Jack: total damage...
Jack: Doesn't call your bluff the total damage I say
UNKNOWN: is the thing. Yeah, but
Kakashi: that will be half because it's piercing, right?
Jack: Uh...
UNKNOWN: Yes. Okay. That's what I
Kakashi: was asking. Uh...
SPEAKER_07: There we go.
Kakashi: Alright. Uh...
UNKNOWN: Alright. Uh, you wanna
Kakashi: shoot again?
Jack: Uh, the real damage was 9, by the way.
Kakashi: That's fine.
Kakashi: That's fine. I don't think it would've...
UNKNOWN: was worth it. Yeah, I know, but I
Jack: just wanted to do it once. Yeah.
Kakashi: That's nice. It could be fun
Kakashi: when it's, like, critical.
Kakashi: Hits and everything. The max damage I can do is
Jack: 21. Yeah.
Kakashi: Exactly.
Jack: Uh, but let me shoot again.
Jack: Let's go...
Kakashi: 28 hit size. Uh... Yes.
Kakashi: Dammit. You almost have the same
Kakashi: modifier as Mira. Plus 5, plus 5.
Jack: 18.
Jack: Yeah, 18.
Kakashi: Uh, so that's, like, another 9.
Kakashi: Right?
Jack: Yeah, yeah. If it's all damage.
UNKNOWN: Uh, alright. The both... Both of
Kakashi: those shots, as she was, like, turning
Kakashi: around while you ran away, you just
Kakashi: shoot her as you were, like, uh,
Kakashi: running backwards. Uh...
Kakashi: She's just gonna take those on her
Kakashi: shoulders and she's just gonna keep
Kakashi: running. Uh...
Kakashi: Towards you.
Kakashi: And at last, she
Kakashi: grows Brick Fists.
Kakashi: And just, like, a barrage of punches.
Kakashi: Uh... Hit you.
Kakashi: All at once.
UNKNOWN: Yeah.
Kakashi: Horror and Arm Strikes. Normal.
Kakashi: 27 hits.
UNKNOWN: Yeah. And 22.
Kakashi: Again, with
Kakashi: one of these hits, she can throw
Kakashi: people 15 feet away.
Kakashi: So she's gonna just punch you.
Kakashi: And, like, a gust of
Kakashi: wind just hits you right in the stomach as you
Kakashi: fall, uh, unconscious
Kakashi: 15 feet away.
Kakashi: Uh...
Kakashi: And after,
Kakashi: uh, Trey has healed
Kakashi: each and every one of you, you get
Kakashi: back up. Uh...
Kakashi: And you see Mira just, like, sitting
Kakashi: while Trey is, like,
Kakashi: punching away the
Kakashi: wounds that just
Kakashi: K'ed you and...
Kakashi: Bob, did you hit her?
Kakashi: No, I don't think you did.
Kakashi: Uh... Yeah.
Kakashi: She's healing those
Kakashi: while you all come back to
Kakashi: uh...
Kakashi: the living.
UNKNOWN: I held out the longest.
Kakashi: Uh... As you all
Kakashi: recovered, she stands up
Kakashi: and she
Kakashi: asks you guys to, like,
Kakashi: uh... stand around.
UNKNOWN: You guys can, uh...
Roma: short rest
Kakashi: to recover all your hit points.
UNKNOWN: Yay.
UNKNOWN: Uh...
Kakashi: Don't use any die, just recover fully.
Kakashi: And then... use all the die
Kakashi: and then, uh... remove
Kakashi: the... what do you call it?
Kakashi: The used up die. So you're
Kakashi: not using any die because, uh...
Kakashi: Trey is healing you.
Jack: So essentially a long rest. Yeah, essentially
Kakashi: a long rest, but without any dies.
Roma: Uh...
UNKNOWN: Not real long rest because you're not recovering
Kakashi: any of the long rest
Kakashi: stuff back.
Kakashi: Uh... That's fine.
Kakashi: That's fine. I don't think it matters anyway.
Kakashi: Uh... Alright.
Kakashi: As you guys, uh...
Kakashi: recover and
Kakashi: stand around, uh...
Kakashi: she will, uh... stand
Kakashi: up and try to address
Kakashi: each and every one.
Kakashi: Okay, um...
Kakashi: You have put
Kakashi: surprisingly, uh...
Kakashi: a lot of
Kakashi: uh...
Kakashi: resistance against me.
Kakashi: Honestly, Trey is down
Kakashi: usually in one hit. So I'm not
Kakashi: used to this. Uh...
UNKNOWN: All
Kakashi: I
Kakashi: am going to
Kakashi: tell you is...
Kakashi: You will not be able to fight
Kakashi: someone like me, or somewhere close
Kakashi: to me. I
Kakashi: don't think at this level you can
Kakashi: even beat Tom. Yet.
Kakashi: And by the
Kakashi: end of this, I just want all of you to
Kakashi: maybe fight
Kakashi: head on with Tom.
Kakashi: At the very least. And
Kakashi: that's what I'm expecting. Don't
Kakashi: worry, I will whip this one into shape
Kakashi: with you as well.
Kakashi: She looks at Trey. And, uh...
Kakashi: How many of you
Kakashi: are aware
Kakashi: of what Haki is?
UNKNOWN: I'll raise my
Roma: hand partially.
UNKNOWN: Oh! Okay.
UNKNOWN: He knows!
UNKNOWN: Okay.
Roma: Of course he knows.
Kakashi: He's been around me and...
Kakashi: the old man a while.
Kakashi: I'm just worried about the rest.
Bob: I have experienced
Bob: some Hakis to my face.
UNKNOWN: Yeah. Okay.
Kakashi: That's a good thing. Believe it or not.
Kakashi: If you have come in contact
Kakashi: with a Haki user, there's a higher chance
Kakashi: that you might be able
Kakashi: to wield your own Haki. But that's
Kakashi: not here or there.
Kakashi: Depends on your
Kakashi: ability to
Kakashi: uh...
Kakashi: impose your will
Kakashi: on others. That's what Haki is.
Kakashi: At the core of it.
Kakashi: Well, there's three forms of Haki
Kakashi: if you don't know.
Kakashi: One is observation.
Kakashi: One is armament. And
Kakashi: one is, of course,
Kakashi: this. Everyone, uh...
Kakashi: make a...
UNKNOWN: Wisdom save.
Roma: Wisdom?
UNKNOWN: Haha!
Roma: But please stop quitting!
Roma: Please don't quit
Roma: for the rest of us!
Roma: He gets a crit and I get a fucking two.
Roma: Hahaha!
UNKNOWN: That's crazy.
Kakashi: Can you make a roll for Cade
Kakashi: as well, Baptiste?
UNKNOWN: Yeah.
SPEAKER_07: Bob failed. Baptiste failed. Everyone failed.
SPEAKER_07: Cade is left.
SPEAKER_07: I'm
SPEAKER_07: gonna make a Wisdom save for Lou.
SPEAKER_07: It's not worth it, but I'll make anyway.
UNKNOWN: I'm gonna make a save for
Roma: Vodka too.
SPEAKER_07: Seventeen. Okay. That's not bad.
SPEAKER_07: But she's still not gonna...
SPEAKER_07: survive.
Roma: Who else? Who else?
Roma: Oh, yeah. Of course.
UNKNOWN: Our boy Trey!
Roma: Trey! No.
Kakashi: He's gonna pass out first.
Kakashi: You see as
Kakashi: Mira's eyes widen up
Kakashi: as this burst of energy just
Kakashi: flows through her.
Kakashi: As
Kakashi: you see Trey kind of
Kakashi: falls down on his back.
Kakashi: Everyone else also.
Kakashi: Baptiste, you stay
Kakashi: like
Kakashi: standing. And
Kakashi: Mira walks up to you and she goes
UNKNOWN: Well, I guess
Kakashi: it was a good thing you
Kakashi: were me and the captain for
Kakashi: a while, huh?
Kakashi: Let's wait for the rest to come back and then
Kakashi: we can continue our training.
Jack: Baptiste also
Jack: fell unconscious when Alice...
UNKNOWN: What?
Jack: Baptiste also went
Jack: down when Alice...
Kakashi: Yeah, yeah, yeah. That's a different thing.
Kakashi: That's a different thing.
Kakashi: It's not like inherently...
Kakashi: Yeah, it's not inherent. It's just like
Kakashi: now he's able to withstand it. Usually
Kakashi: he's not.
Kakashi: You don't need to ride on it.
Baptiste: It's different per person.
UNKNOWN: Yeah.
SPEAKER_08: No, it doesn't depend on per person.
SPEAKER_08: It's just like maybe you're exposed to it
SPEAKER_08: a bit more than usual.
UNKNOWN: Alright.
Kakashi: Okay, you all
Kakashi: come back to
Kakashi: consciousness
Kakashi: in a bit.
Kakashi: Well, Baptiste is like taking care of Lou
Kakashi: and Mira has
Kakashi: Trey on her lap.
Kakashi: As Trey wakes up and
Kakashi: he
Kakashi: gets up away from Mira
Kakashi: and just stands up straight and he's like
Kakashi: I'm sorry, I'm sorry, I'm sorry, I'm sorry.
Kakashi: You're fine, Trey. It's
Kakashi: okay.
Kakashi: Alright.
Kakashi: She will
Kakashi: get up and ask
Kakashi: everyone if they have felt
Kakashi: any
Kakashi: presence of
Kakashi: unnatural strength before this
Kakashi: at any moment.
UNKNOWN: On multiple
Roma: cases. Define unnatural.
UNKNOWN: Unnatural
Kakashi: in the sense that
Kakashi: sometimes you feel like
Kakashi: you can't make
UNKNOWN: a
Kakashi: hit but then suddenly
Kakashi: you feel like a sudden burst of energy
Kakashi: and then you're able to
Kakashi: do something. Either
Kakashi: perceive a danger
Kakashi: incoming or
Kakashi: protect yourself
Kakashi: from something or
Kakashi: impact something else.
Bob: Oh, I feel like most of us
Bob: have because there was this one time
Bob: I shot a bell
Bob: and I didn't feel like I could hit it
Bob: but then I shot and it hit.
UNKNOWN: Huh.
UNKNOWN: I suppose
Kakashi: you will have
Kakashi: a better chance with
Kakashi: observation.
Kakashi: So I'll focus on that.
Kakashi: Uh, Roma?
UNKNOWN: Do you have something? I mean
SPEAKER_13: there's times where I black out and I
SPEAKER_13: wake up covered in
SPEAKER_13: stuff.
Kakashi: I think that's just
Kakashi: a different thing all
Kakashi: together.
Kakashi: Uh, have you used
Kakashi: any form of hockey before?
Kakashi: Probably not if you're not aware
Kakashi: of it.
UNKNOWN: Alright.
Kakashi: We'll work on you on
Kakashi: both aspects. Both observation
Kakashi: and armament.
Kakashi: Jack, how about you?
Jack: Uh, it was really easy to
Jack: get into it.
Roma: Alright. Uh,
Roma: you there, Kade. How about you?
UNKNOWN: She looks at Kade. Kade
Kakashi: will probably just nod no.
Kakashi: He has not
Kakashi: felt any type of
Kakashi: way. And
Kakashi: lastly, Baptiste.
Kakashi: How about it?
Baptiste: Um, I
Baptiste: thought it on multiplications
Baptiste: actually.
Baptiste: Okay, that's good to
Roma: know.
Kakashi: Uh, I'm gonna
Kakashi: maybe try focusing
Kakashi: on all the aspects.
Kakashi: You might have
Kakashi: some potential
Kakashi: in using Conquerors, but
Kakashi: we'll discuss that later.
Kakashi: Right now, I
Kakashi: want you
Kakashi: to not use any of your Devil Fruit
Kakashi: powers. Not
Kakashi: use any of your
Kakashi: inherent
Kakashi: powers and just use
Kakashi: your raw strength.
Kakashi: That's it.
Kakashi: And we will fight
Kakashi: day and
Kakashi: night over and over
Kakashi: until you show me
Kakashi: you are capable of handling
Kakashi: yourself. Is that clear?
Baptiste: Easy enough.
UNKNOWN: Alright.
Kakashi: Now, see, uh,
Kakashi: I want to make sure that
Kakashi: none of this
Kakashi: is sending the wrong message.
Kakashi: This is not to humiliate you. This is not
UNKNOWN: to tell
Kakashi: you that you're weak. This is to
Kakashi: tell you that this is
Kakashi: where our enemy's strengths are.
UNKNOWN: And
Kakashi: unfortunately,
Kakashi: our spy's unit
Kakashi: has disappeared, so I have no
Kakashi: clue what the enemy has in store
Kakashi: for us.
Kakashi: The best defense
Kakashi: is the best offense.
UNKNOWN: So, I'm
Kakashi: gonna train you
Kakashi: to hold your own, and
Kakashi: maybe by the end of it, you
Kakashi: get something out of this.
Baptiste: Do you mean the unit I used to
Baptiste: be a part of?
Kakashi: Uh, well, you mostly
Kakashi: operated alone,
Kakashi: but yeah, some of the other
Kakashi: alone
Kakashi: pirates are also
Kakashi: not responding anymore. I sent
Kakashi: Akira a while back to
Kakashi: check on what
Kakashi: happened in the North
Kakashi: Blue, but I haven't heard back from him.
Kakashi: And, uh,
Kakashi: hopefully we hear back
Kakashi: from Drovan at one point.
Kakashi: If he finds Goro,
Kakashi: then that's good
Kakashi: for us, and
Kakashi: otherwise, we'll have to
Kakashi: go do that
Kakashi: ourselves at one point.
Kakashi: Alright, I'll give you
Kakashi: 10-20 minutes
Kakashi: to rest up, and
Kakashi: then we will go, again.
Kakashi: Alright, I think we can end
SPEAKER_07: the session here, because
SPEAKER_07: Bob has to go.
Roma: Yeah, thanks.
Roma: Alright.
UNKNOWN: Well, this is essentially the training.
Kakashi: This is gonna just go on and on
Kakashi: and on and on. The next,
Kakashi: Bob, you don't need to be here for this, but I'm just
Kakashi: going to tell you the
Kakashi: basics, and then you can leave.
Kakashi: Basically, the training arc was
Kakashi: my idea, because
Kakashi: the thing is, like, you guys have been
Kakashi: in, like, combats again
Kakashi: and again. I want to keep it,
Kakashi: the leveling up, tied up to
Kakashi: the real world
Kakashi: somewhat, so
Kakashi: I wanted a reason why you would level up
Kakashi: again. Last time, it was
Kakashi: like something, sort of an awakening
Kakashi: type deal, and now it's training arcs.
Kakashi: But I'm giving you
UNKNOWN: two levels in this
Kakashi: training arc. What?
Jack: Can I comment for a
UNKNOWN: second? Yeah.
Jack: I had to
Jack: look at the hockey thing on the
Jack: PDF, but it says
Jack: what's it called?
Jack: Journeyman, like, not Journeyman,
Jack: but
Jack: apprentice starts, or
Jack: no, novice starts at level eight.
Kakashi: Yeah, I took that
Kakashi: in consideration,
UNKNOWN: and
Kakashi: I wanted to ask you guys,
Kakashi: I can give you some
Kakashi: preliminary form of hockey
Kakashi: right now, so you can test
Kakashi: it out a little bit, and
Kakashi: then you can finalize on which one you
Kakashi: want to use.
Kakashi: So, you can either go the
Kakashi: observation route,
Kakashi: the armament route, or the
Kakashi: conqueror's route. The conqueror's route will be
Kakashi: like, pretty
Kakashi: on and off. It's gonna go off,
Kakashi: on moments, on story moments
Kakashi: for now, and after a point,
Kakashi: I will let you use it, like, freely.
Kakashi: Whoever is going to go
Kakashi: that route.
Jack: I'm doing observation also
Jack: because of other reasons. Yes.
UNKNOWN: Yes. And that's
Kakashi: default for you, but the rest can
Kakashi: maybe try it out.
Kakashi: Yeah.
Kakashi: Because of reasons that we will not
UNKNOWN: get into. So,
Kakashi: I can give you three levels.
Kakashi: I have no problem with giving you three levels, right?
Jack: Because the only thing that I would give is
Jack: another sheet. Yes.
Kakashi: So,
Kakashi: you guys can decide
Kakashi: and we can level up your
Kakashi: temporary characters right now
Kakashi: and try to see it.
Kakashi: Bob, you can leave. We can get your
Kakashi: character up at any point when you
Kakashi: have some free time, or next week.
Bob: Today, I'm
Bob: pretty free, because
Bob: Xanathar has some
Bob: time to start, so today if we can finish it,
Bob: I'll... Yeah, yeah. So, let's
Kakashi: just finish it. Finish your
Kakashi: character up then.
Kakashi: Okay, so... We can do Bob first
Baptiste: for now. Yeah. Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Kakashi: Let's do Bob first, but I need
Kakashi: like, the decision. Do you
Kakashi: want three levels or two levels for now?
Baptiste: Let's do three!
Kakashi: Alright, let's go!
UNKNOWN: What do you think
Bob: we would say? We would say, don't give us three
Jack: levels. Yeah, but we probably won't
Jack: get a level up again for like months
Jack: ahead now. Yeah, yeah.
UNKNOWN: Hey,
Baptiste: it's been that long already.
UNKNOWN: True.
SPEAKER_07: We're fighting for a
SPEAKER_07: level up every Saturday.
Bob: I'm just gonna start crying again,
Bob: level us up, and he's gonna level
UNKNOWN: us up. No, I feel like
Bob: we should be... I also, again,
Kakashi: I want you guys to keep this in mind.
Kakashi: This is going to be a month.
Kakashi: There's going to be a month's time skip.
Kakashi: Between now and then.
Kakashi: That's why, Bob, I asked you to
Kakashi: maybe get like a new character art
Kakashi: for your character, because I think Bob can
Kakashi: change a lot in that time.
Kakashi: Because he's like shifting from one
Kakashi: archetype to another.
Kakashi: So I felt like maybe a redesign
Kakashi: for your character would work.
Kakashi: The rest can stay mostly the same.
Kakashi: If you want like minor tweaks
Kakashi: to your character design, you can suggest those.
Kakashi: But other than that, I think
Kakashi: everyone's good for now.
Jack: Not into the way I looked.
Kakashi: Yeah, you're just joined
Kakashi: so it's fine. Yeah.
Jack: But Roma or Baptiste,
Kakashi: if you guys have any like
Kakashi: tweaks to your character design
Kakashi: you want to pitch, I'm open to it.
Kakashi: Okay, let's finish up Bob first.
Roma: Level up.
Roma: Exciting, isn't it?
Bob: Yes.
Kakashi: No, no, no. I'm going to give you the sheets
Kakashi: later on, but let's
Kakashi: decide what you want right now, so I can
Kakashi: maybe plan accordingly.
Bob: Maybe I can...
Bob: Because at the...
Kakashi: We can go through it right now
Kakashi: with the other people
Kakashi: so they are also aware.
Bob: Okay, super.
UNKNOWN: Okay.
Kakashi: Alright, so let's first go
Kakashi: with like the basic stuff, which is...
Kakashi: Level up.
Jack: Okay.
Kakashi: Bob, can you give me a...
Kakashi: D10?
Bob: Will do.
Roma: You can do it on Discord, you can do it here.
Roma: Whatever.
Roma: D8. Next.
UNKNOWN: Next.
UNKNOWN: Okay.
Roma: Another D8.
Roma: No, D10, sorry.
Roma: Mmm...
Roma: 6.
Roma: Which is the average, okay.
Kakashi: Aura of Warding...
Kakashi: Is this correct?
Kakashi: Aura of Warding?
Roma: Another D10?
Roma: Because I think you're using the base palette
Kakashi: and you'll have to change this stuff
Kakashi: or let me know what you want
Kakashi: in case you have like different
Kakashi: stuff for it.
Kakashi: Okay, I'll take average in this case
Kakashi: because it's lower.
Kakashi: Okay, ASI or feat.
Kakashi: You don't have to decide now.
Kakashi: You can decide later.
Bob: If you want a feat.
Bob: Okay, what do you want?
Bob: The Axe Master
Bob: one. It's
Bob: in the book, if you can search it out.
Roma: Is it not here
Roma: by default?
Roma: It's in the
Roma: book?
UNKNOWN: It should be here too.
Roma: Oh, it's in the source book
Roma: you're saying.
Bob: Yeah, it was something
Bob: with Axe Mastery.
Bob: Just Axe Mastery, something like that.
Roma: Next.
Roma: Oh, there we go.
Roma: Just add this.
UNKNOWN: What the fuck do you mean?
Roma: It is...
Roma: It is a feat. What?
Roma: I think it needs to be in the book.
SPEAKER_07: Okay, so you'll take
SPEAKER_07: a feat then. I can just
SPEAKER_07: assume that.
SPEAKER_07: Okay, let's go Haki.
UNKNOWN: Okay, which
Kakashi: one do you want?
Kakashi: Haki itself is more reward based
Kakashi: but requires the party to be at least level
Kakashi: 8 to achieve it. Haki will be described more
Kakashi: in depth, but
Kakashi: most Haki systems use Haki dice.
Kakashi: Not mechanic
Kakashi: would destroy the balance. Too much damage
Kakashi: means...
Kakashi: every level, too many hit points
Kakashi: means I have to buff the magic, so on.
Kakashi: Boy, Nightmare Haki is mostly based on
Kakashi: proficiency bonus. With all that said,
Kakashi: I hope you enjoy the system and have fun while...
Roma: Okay.
Roma: Where's the rules?
UNKNOWN: Wait, this is just the...
Roma: Oh, this is the prologue.
Kakashi: I was looking at the prologue.
Kakashi: Okay, you can
Kakashi: choose starting
Kakashi: with these two. You will have
Kakashi: access to only these two. Conquerors is
Kakashi: mostly story based.
Kakashi: And I don't think Bob will have
Kakashi: Conquerors Haki.
Kakashi: So, this type of Haki
Kakashi: observation will grant
Kakashi: you...
Kakashi: Where is it?
UNKNOWN: Level
Kakashi: 8. Where is it?
Kakashi: There's no level, though.
Jack: Basically, Bob,
Jack: like Iron Man this, you hit that.
Jack: Oh yeah, there you go. Sense Presence.
Kakashi: That's your feat.
Kakashi: Sense Presence at 8th level.
Kakashi: You can become far more observant.
Kakashi: Gain plus 5
Kakashi: bonus to your passive perception score.
Kakashi: In place of the search
Kakashi: action, you can instead focus and become
Kakashi: aware of a living creature within 60 feet
UNKNOWN: of you that isn't hidden.
Kakashi: A hidden creature must immediately
Kakashi: make a dexterity
Kakashi: stealth check against your
Kakashi: passive perception or be spotted. You instantly
Kakashi: learn the size of the creature but do not learn
Kakashi: the exact
Kakashi: location unless you see it.
Kakashi: Focusing. You have a pool of
Kakashi: observation points equal to the level that
Kakashi: replenishes when
Kakashi: you take a short or long rest.
Kakashi: When you make an attack roll or a force target
Kakashi: that makes a saving throw,
Kakashi: you can expend an observation point
Kakashi: to add half your proficiency bonus
Kakashi: rounded down to the attack roll
Kakashi: or DC.
UNKNOWN: Okay? Okay.
Kakashi: You can expend only one observation point
Kakashi: per attack or DC.
Kakashi: Essentially, you will have a pool of
Kakashi: Haki points that you can use
Kakashi: as observation points
Kakashi: or armament points
Kakashi: either way. But for now,
Kakashi: I will only give you access to one of them.
Kakashi: So you can choose between
Kakashi: if you want this or this.
Kakashi: I'll tell you the armament
Kakashi: one. Okay, these are
Kakashi: you get from level 8.
Kakashi: This one you will unlock at level 10.
Kakashi: And
Kakashi: where's the armament
Kakashi: one?
Kakashi: There you go. Armor of resolve
Kakashi: your will that refuses your
Kakashi: body when you take damage from any sword
Kakashi: it is less than or equal to 5
Kakashi: you ignore that damage.
Kakashi: That's why Mira didn't
Kakashi: take like damage below
Kakashi: whatever it was
Kakashi: 5 or below.
Kakashi: This damage threshold is calculated
Kakashi: before any damage reduction
Kakashi: and resistance.
Kakashi: So if like
Kakashi: let's say you're doing 15 damage
Kakashi: it will knock off the 5
Kakashi: damage first and then half that.
UNKNOWN: Okay?
Bob: That sounds awesome.
Kakashi: I think
Kakashi: for your character armament might
Kakashi: be better because it's like armor
Kakashi: and everything. I mean it is like a tank
Bob: and whatnot. Yeah.
Bob: I do have resistance. In addition
Kakashi: if you have ocean scorn feature you are
Kakashi: affected by the knee deep weakness
Kakashi: you can ignore those effects except being
Kakashi: unable to activate your
UNKNOWN: devil fruit. Which is
Kakashi: I don't know why it's added here. That's not the thing.
Jack: Nothing applies to Bob.
Kakashi: That's not gonna apply to you
Kakashi: anyway. Enhancement your attacks
Kakashi: are also enhanced
Kakashi: which is your strikes making your
Kakashi: fists, bullets, blades, other weapons
Kakashi: more dense allowing you to smash
Kakashi: through all that comes. Your attacks
Kakashi: and creatures now overcome resistances
Kakashi: and immunities. Essentially Logias
Kakashi: you can now hit with full damage
Kakashi: instead of whatever half damage they were taking.
Kakashi: And
Kakashi: you have a pool of
Kakashi: attack points equal to your level that replenishes
Kakashi: when you take a short rest. So any attack
Kakashi: that you imbue with Haki will attack for
Kakashi: whatever. Like full damage.
Kakashi: When you deal
Kakashi: damage within attack creation
Kakashi: you can spend attack
Kakashi: point to half or whatever. It's the same
Kakashi: rules with the thing. You can
Kakashi: expand number of attack points, single
Kakashi: damage rule to equal blah blah blah.
Kakashi: If you have affinity to Ars Argon you may add
Kakashi: your full proficiency bonus rather than a half.
Kakashi: And fortified defense
Kakashi: adds AC
Kakashi: again. When you use dodge
Kakashi: action you can additionally
Kakashi: gain advantage of a saving throw of your
Kakashi: choice in addition to
Kakashi: dexterity until the start
Kakashi: of next turn.
Kakashi: Not AC.
Kakashi: If I was like
Bob: still a wizard I think observation
Bob: would be better for me.
Bob: Since I'm doing Paladin way
Bob: let's just do Armament.
Kakashi: I've had like Haki points
Kakashi: here and all these feats here
Kakashi: for Armament
Kakashi: Haki.
Kakashi: And what does this say about affinity?
Bob: How do you get that?
Kakashi: Affinity
Kakashi: towards Armament
Kakashi: Affinity rules
Kakashi: I have to check.
UNKNOWN: I don't know how affinity
UNKNOWN: rules work. You may add
Roma: your full proficiency bonus rather than
UNKNOWN: half. I don't know
SPEAKER_07: what that means. I'll look into it.
Bob: How do you get affinity?
Bob: Nevermind.
Bob: So like when we are doing it
Bob: are we like
Bob: using with affinity or
Bob: without affinity?
Roma: I don't know why it says half.
Kakashi: When you deal damage
Kakashi: with an attack or other damage you can
Kakashi: spend attack point to half
Kakashi: your proficiency bonus rounded down to the
Kakashi: damage roll. You can spend the number of
Kakashi: damage roll maximum equal to the proficiency
Kakashi: bonus.
Kakashi: If you have affinity towards Armament Haki you can
Kakashi: I think you get it later maybe.
Kakashi: Affinity.
Jack: Go a bit down.
Jack: A bit more.
Jack: At the bottom
Jack: it says something.
Jack: Yeah there you go. When a player gains
Kakashi: their first Haki ability the first one
Kakashi: typically the one they have the
Kakashi: most affinity for. So
Kakashi: if you choose
Kakashi: what do you call it? Armament Haki
Kakashi: that's the Haki you have the affinity
Kakashi: for. And going forward
Kakashi: if you choose observation at level 16
Kakashi: or something. I don't know when it is.
Kakashi: I think it's 12. I think it's 12.
Bob: It's for multiple Haki uses
Jack: right? For your first Haki ability
Jack: it's 4 but the others ones are
UNKNOWN: gonna be off. Yeah so if you
Kakashi: use observation Haki at
Kakashi: any point later on
Kakashi: that's gonna be halved.
Kakashi: Whatever affinity you have on those.
Kakashi: Got it.
UNKNOWN: Got it.
Kakashi: Do you get all of them?
Bob: Yeah.
Kakashi: I don't think you get all of them right? You have to choose
UNKNOWN: one? The first
Roma: Haki
Jack: Typically when Haki is achieved you only
Kakashi: you learn only one
Kakashi: and then one dictates your Haki proficiency
Kakashi: you will learn as you are supposed to
Kakashi: one type of Haki is sort of yeah
Kakashi: they can still multiple however every
Kakashi: two levels after initially learning Haki
Kakashi: the characters will gain the option of learning an additional
Kakashi: step. Yeah I think I remember
Kakashi: I think it was something like 8 you learn
UNKNOWN: Yeah
Jack: Yeah you learn it first
Jack: and then at 10 you can either
Kakashi: Yeah 10 you can
Jack: or get another one. Yeah
Kakashi: either you can get more proficiency in it
Kakashi: or you can learn a different one
Kakashi: and same at 12
Kakashi: and 16
Kakashi: I think then maybe
Jack: I don't know
Jack: 14
Roma: 14 and then 16
Jack: 14 and 16 yeah
Jack: every other level
UNKNOWN: I think 16 is max
UNKNOWN: right? Yeah
Roma: until this goes
Roma: you won't make it to 16 that's fine
UNKNOWN: Oh
Jack: you'll die before then
Roma: No I think you'll get bored before
UNKNOWN: Okay
Roma: No
Kakashi: the combat gets a bit too messy
Kakashi: after like a 10
Kakashi: even like 11 is hard
Kakashi: to get through
Kakashi: so 8, 9, 10
Kakashi: probably 12 maybe max
Kakashi: we will cap at 12 and end
Kakashi: the campaign there
Kakashi: alright so I think that's it
Kakashi: you can look into your class
Kakashi: and subclass and let me know if
Kakashi: anything is missing from the thing
Kakashi: it probably is most likely
Kakashi: because I did not import any of that
Kakashi: I think you only worked on it
Kakashi: on your own
Kakashi: I should have probably looked at it
Kakashi: but it's fine
Kakashi: 101 HP
Kakashi: okay
Kakashi: you're pretty tanky now
Bob: No it's much less than that
Bob: I think the constitution buff is still on
Bob: if you turn it off it will be lowered
Bob: Oh
Bob: No no not that just in the effects
UNKNOWN: in the effects tab
Bob: I think if you turn off the
Bob: flexible body
Bob: at the very top of effects
Roma: I see
Bob: turn off flexible body
Roma: oh I see I see
Roma: makes sense makes sense
UNKNOWN: okay
Kakashi: okay you can look into it
Kakashi: let me know if you want to change up
Kakashi: the character designs or anything
Kakashi: you can look into it
Kakashi: okay
Kakashi: maybe I'll look some on
Kakashi: Pinterest and maybe ping you
Kakashi: some suggestions
SPEAKER_07: we'll see
Kakashi: alright you can
Kakashi: you can leave if you want to
Kakashi: after training Baptiste
Kakashi: what I look like in this photo is
Kakashi: bulky and chubby
Roma: alright see you next week man
UNKNOWN: what
Roma: what was I saying
Kakashi: alright who wants to go next
Kakashi: after training Baptiste
Kakashi: is gonna look like this photo
Kakashi: his current bounty has him looking bulky and chubby
Kakashi: hahaha nice
Roma: with the fucking
Roma: thing yeah
Roma: like look at his hands in his
Roma: current bounty poster
UNKNOWN: uh
Roma: oh not here
Roma: yeah
Roma: something went wrong with the
Roma: generation
Roma: I didn't even notice man
Roma: it is it is very chubby bro
Roma: what the fuck
Roma: yeah you know it just doesn't
Roma: do one to one images anymore
UNKNOWN: has to add
Roma: his own twang
Roma: everyone wants vodka
Kakashi: what about gin come on
Kakashi: give him a chance
Roma: nope
Roma: okay no
Roma: alright who wants to go next
UNKNOWN: I'm still looking
UNKNOWN: I can
UNKNOWN: alright
UNKNOWN: okay let me move
UNKNOWN: wait
SPEAKER_07: should've copied
SPEAKER_07: well I guess I'll just move it doesn't matter
Kakashi: uh okay but
Kakashi: at the end you will have
Kakashi: another fight with trey
Kakashi: not trey fucking thompson
Kakashi: so that's the
Kakashi: essentially just like
Kakashi: uh wrapping up the
Kakashi: training arc you will have just a
Kakashi: one on one with thompson
Kakashi: which will be a more realistically
Kakashi: uh
Kakashi: doable fight it should be
Kakashi: but I don't know
Kakashi: trey is kind of a
Kakashi: thompson is kind of a
Kakashi: monster in his own right
Kakashi: uh okay let's go
Kakashi: yeah
UNKNOWN: it's very
Kakashi: yeah it's very dependent on
Kakashi: um
Kakashi: just luck I think
Kakashi: there's not a lot of strategy in the one we want
Kakashi: okay which one do you want
Kakashi: more points in
Kakashi: barbarian fighter
UNKNOWN: uh
UNKNOWN: you have three levels
UNKNOWN: yeah do two
Roma: to barbarian and then one to fight
UNKNOWN: better
Jack: let's go
UNKNOWN: all right
Roma: let's go uh
Roma: a roll uh
Roma: 1d12
UNKNOWN: play some music
UNKNOWN: seven
Roma: go there you go
Roma: oh it was seven nice
UNKNOWN: uh okay asi
Kakashi: or feet
Roma: uh hold on
Kakashi: four feet
Roma: that's what I was thinking what
Roma: can I get um uh
Kakashi: you can look into the book or
Kakashi: you can look into
Kakashi: if you want to go feet we can decide
Kakashi: later and we can also decide which one
Kakashi: you want honestly
Kakashi: asi or feet it's up to you
UNKNOWN: no I need to increase my wisdom
Roma: I'm tired every fucking roll is a wisdom
Roma: yeah
Kakashi: uh all right make a
Kakashi: 1d12 again
Kakashi: let's take average next
Kakashi: devil fruit uses increases
UNKNOWN: uh all right one in
Kakashi: barbarian fighter right
UNKNOWN: yep
Kakashi: do a 1d10
UNKNOWN: let's take average
SPEAKER_07: martial archetype
SPEAKER_07: okay subclass what do you want
UNKNOWN: uh
Kakashi: you can think about it if you're
Kakashi: not sure
Roma: samurai or
UNKNOWN: samurai wouldn't make
Kakashi: sense for roman
Baptiste: arcane archer
Kakashi: arcane archer
SPEAKER_07: uh let me
SPEAKER_07: check here uh
UNKNOWN: fighter there's
Baptiste: one in um
Baptiste: the one I'm also looking on dnd beyond
Baptiste: let me look at what the one
SPEAKER_07: piece ones have and then we can
SPEAKER_07: look at the other ones
Jack: I'm also yeah I've gone look at them
Baptiste: the one piece one has one
Baptiste: called brute
Kakashi: does it ooh brute yeah
Kakashi: the powerful brute focuses
Kakashi: on the use of raw physical
Kakashi: power hone to deadly perfection
Kakashi: those who model themselves on this archetype
Kakashi: and rigorous training with physical
Kakashi: excellence to deal devastating blows
Kakashi: and take heavy hits brute
Kakashi: force starting at level third you
Kakashi: whenever you hit with a weapon that fight
Kakashi: that you're proficient with and
Kakashi: deal damage the weapons damage increases by
Kakashi: 1d4 this feature also works with
Kakashi: unarmed strikes this bonus
Kakashi: becomes 1d6 at level five
Kakashi: so on unstoppable durability
Kakashi: third wind
Kakashi: that's level 10 though so
Kakashi: the only thing you get will be
Kakashi: unstoppable durability beginning of level
Kakashi: seven whenever you make a saving
Kakashi: throw roll 1d6 add the
Kakashi: die to the saving throw total
Kakashi: if applying this bonus to it that
Kakashi: saving throw increases the total 20
Kakashi: or higher you gain benefits
Kakashi: of rolling 20 on the d20
Kakashi: nice so if it's like 21
Kakashi: that's essentially treated as
Kakashi: nat 20
UNKNOWN: that's level
UNKNOWN: seven yeah that is level
SPEAKER_07: seven but oh yeah that's level
SPEAKER_07: seven no never mind you don't
SPEAKER_07: get this you only get the brute force
Roma: which that's still fine
Roma: i'll take that
SPEAKER_07: nice uh
SPEAKER_07: i'll add it later
SPEAKER_07: uh
SPEAKER_07: get you to what
SPEAKER_07: subclass
SPEAKER_07: brute
UNKNOWN: you can't multiply clients
Jack: no what would you multiclass to
UNKNOWN: i'm looking
UNKNOWN: all right
SPEAKER_07: jackaboy
UNKNOWN: oh yay me
Baptiste: wisdom index based
Kakashi: also you have to figure
Kakashi: out uh kate's
Kakashi: stuff too about
UNKNOWN: these oh he's
UNKNOWN: just going to level four with
Jack: yeah he gets a feat
UNKNOWN: oh i gotta figure
Kakashi: out his speed all right you're gonna go
Kakashi: level eight on gunslinger
Kakashi: um yes sir
Kakashi: guessing okay
Kakashi: roll a 1d8
UNKNOWN: it's d8
Jack: oh yeah i thought it was
SPEAKER_08: why do you think you have 36
SPEAKER_08: hp
Jack: keep rolling you also have a low con
UNKNOWN: right yeah you also have a
SPEAKER_08: little 12 yeah
UNKNOWN: uh
UNKNOWN: d8
UNKNOWN: okay take average
UNKNOWN: so risk die
Kakashi: risky business all right
Kakashi: roll another d8
UNKNOWN: hey
Jack: i don't think i'm above a five
Jack: five
SPEAKER_08: evasion almost
Jack: all of my left almost all of my
Jack: levels have become a five
Jack: because i keep going below
UNKNOWN: all right
Kakashi: and then again
Jack: hey it's happening nice
SPEAKER_07: okay yes i have
UNKNOWN: feet what feet
Jack: observant
UNKNOWN: yeah the one piece
Kakashi: observant right
UNKNOWN: there's no there's none
UNKNOWN: i checked
Kakashi: oh there is observant one piece
UNKNOWN: i checked in the
Jack: uh thingies
Baptiste: you didn't check hard enough
Kakashi: quick to know details of your
Kakashi: environment you gain the following benefits increase
Kakashi: your intelligence or wisdom score
UNKNOWN: by one to a maximum of
Kakashi: 20 if you can see a creature's
Kakashi: mouth while
Kakashi: it is speaking a language you understand you can
Kakashi: interpret it what it's saying by reading its
Kakashi: lips you have plus five bonus
Kakashi: to your passive perception and
Kakashi: passive investigation scores
Kakashi: is that acceptable or do you want the
Kakashi: original observant
Jack: oh no it's the same but i was first
Jack: looking at the 2024 one then
Kakashi: whatever the one piece one we can work
Kakashi: with
Jack: yeah but
Jack: it's the same as the
Jack: 14 one but i had the 24 open
UNKNOWN: i see
UNKNOWN: yeah
Jack: also uh
Jack: adding to
Jack: okay which one
Kakashi: yeah list them
Kakashi: uh it's automatically added to
Kakashi: intelligence okay i'll do it and then
Kakashi: i'll change it back
UNKNOWN: yeah i should
SPEAKER_07: 14 this and
SPEAKER_07: 16 this right
Kakashi: yes
UNKNOWN: now you have
Kakashi: almost as much sp as roma had
Kakashi: left level five
UNKNOWN: all right what
Kakashi: are you going with
Kakashi: uh bob was
Kakashi: armament roma did you decide
Kakashi: what hockey
Kakashi: probably armament for you too
Kakashi: i would think
Roma: yeah i'm taking that
Roma: whatever i can
Roma: uh
Kakashi: jack is going
Kakashi: observation
Kakashi: because i have to
UNKNOWN: observation
Roma: yeah well i don't have
Roma: but it makes the most sense
UNKNOWN: yeah uh
Roma: uh
Kakashi: uh four uh
Kakashi: what do you call it two
Kakashi: eights case uh i would have you roll
Kakashi: uh die and it would depend
Kakashi: uh actually i think it works better if
Kakashi: you use it at inspiration
Kakashi: at points where i feel like it's fine
Kakashi: for hockey use so it's gonna be like
Kakashi: how the pc's used hockey before
Kakashi: i baptized uh i still do need
Kakashi: um
Kakashi: conqueror's rules are a bit iffy
UNKNOWN: hey
UNKNOWN: huh conqueror's hockey novice yeah this
Kakashi: is the one you have
Kakashi: okay they have the rules for it okay
Kakashi: that's good
UNKNOWN: you will only have conqueror's hockey
Kakashi: though
UNKNOWN: okay anything new
Kakashi: character thing wise i think there was
Kakashi: something risky business yeah
Kakashi: once per turn you can make an attack
Kakashi: roll against an enemy and the rule
Kakashi: doesn't have
Kakashi: disadvantage you can choose to make the
Kakashi: role with disadvantage when you do you
Kakashi: regain one
Kakashi: one expended risk die
Kakashi: I don't really
Jack: use those dice
Jack: I see
Jack: there's not a lot to use them on
UNKNOWN: you have a risk right?
Jack: yeah but there's no
Jack: the only thing I have is the
Jack: large dice
SPEAKER_09: no you have risk there you go
Jack: yeah but the only thing to use them on
Jack: is the large dice
UNKNOWN: for now
Roma: so you could go
Roma: we need a
Roma: money real quick
Roma: so you know gambling
UNKNOWN: yeah
Roma: you might
UNKNOWN: work on that
Jack: because it needs to be used to maneuvers
UNKNOWN: you don't have any maneuvers?
Jack: yeah it's a lifestyle
UNKNOWN: alright Baptiste
Kakashi: you decide on Cade's stuff
Kakashi: first let's do that
Kakashi: it's gonna be
Kakashi: level 4
Kakashi: so it's gonna go up 2 levels
Roma: okay
Kakashi: okay
SPEAKER_09: okay
SPEAKER_09: make a
SPEAKER_09: 1d8
UNKNOWN: max roll
UNKNOWN: no
UNKNOWN: average
Baptiste: alright
Kakashi: he gets hold a person
Kakashi: spike growth
UNKNOWN: circle spells
Kakashi: okay roll again
Kakashi: what was the circle that you chose?
UNKNOWN: shepherd
Jack: shepherd yeah
UNKNOWN: next
Kakashi: okay ASI or feat
UNKNOWN: I'm gonna give him a feat
UNKNOWN: alright
UNKNOWN: which feat?
Baptiste: I'm going to figure that out later
Baptiste: I'm gonna be scrolling through feats right now
Kakashi: so we will see
Kakashi: okay now he can wild shape into half
Kakashi: which hasn't really changed much
Kakashi: honestly
Kakashi: maybe
UNKNOWN: because we're not using like
Kakashi: it's fine it's fine
Kakashi: let's keep it as a flavor thing
Kakashi: it's fine
Baptiste: this feat actually
Baptiste: I just saw it where'd it go
UNKNOWN: I'm going to give him
Baptiste: survivalist from the one piece book
UNKNOWN: let me see if survivor is the same or not
Kakashi: um
Kakashi: at the start of each turn you regain
Kakashi: hit points equal to 5 plus your constitution modifier
Kakashi: is this the same?
Baptiste: no
Baptiste: in the one piece book
Baptiste: it increases his wisdom score by 1
Baptiste: gains proficiency
Baptiste: in survival skill
Roma: I'll add that then
UNKNOWN: and then he gets the
Baptiste: unarmored AC
Baptiste: he gets the monk AC basically
Baptiste: okay
UNKNOWN: future
Kakashi: survivalist
UNKNOWN: yeah
SPEAKER_07: I think you do already have that
SPEAKER_07: right
UNKNOWN: you also have unarmored
SPEAKER_07: barbarian
UNKNOWN: that's gonna boost
Baptiste: his AC to 17 instead of
Baptiste: 13
Roma: yeah but my AC is only a 15
Jack: is your decks not shite?
UNKNOWN: yeah
Kakashi: my deck seems good
Kakashi: it skills off decks
Jack: that's why you can Jay you can take instead of your wisdom you can put it in
UNKNOWN: decks maybe that will make your AC a bit better or you can maybe get some armor
Kakashi: depending if you can find any armor good enough for using our AC depends we'll
UNKNOWN: see okay Baptiste let's come down to you I'm trying to think I won't multi-class
UNKNOWN: you sound so sad about it so all three levels into brawler and then I'll take a
Kakashi: feat because 1d10 just roll 1d10 three times
Kakashi: oh
UNKNOWN: oh
UNKNOWN: roll 3d time give me 30 30 hey it's two of them are max kind of max and one
Kakashi: average what no that's average man let's go 9
UNKNOWN: take it off shake it off like Taylor Swift all right is I or feet
UNKNOWN: take it off shake it off like Taylor Swift all right is I or feet feet what you want what you really
Kakashi: feet what you want what you really
UNKNOWN: feet what you want what you really really want I'm still scrolling what you
SPEAKER_07: really want I'm still scrolling what you want let me just do that so do you level
Jack: want let me just do that so do you level
Kakashi: want let me just do that so do you level up mouth as well mouth as we'll not miss
Kakashi: up mouth as well mouth as we'll not miss
UNKNOWN: consumption uh spirit right is it uses spirit
Kakashi: okay it'd be good all right let's do malthus sure it doesn't have to be it was just joking
UNKNOWN: no no i have to get him to and i kind of want your input what you're what you would have
UNKNOWN: taken so it's fine brawler level h okay roll 3d 10 let's see if only one of your characters
Roma: are cursed at the time or both are then he came back and now he's all quiet we level up my other
SPEAKER_07: forms too because uh yeah you know what i'll do that first oh you shouldn't have to do anything
UNKNOWN: okay okay roll 310 yay uh let's see if curse of the okay yeah what the
UNKNOWN: three averages oh the curse continues the evidence even in death it follows no i wasn't
UNKNOWN: looking do you want a fee
UNKNOWN: uh
UNKNOWN: i'm looking
Jack: there's so much to look at
Kakashi: and we can decide later it's fine yeah i'll just move on for now
Kakashi: uh the tipsy sway consumes key
SPEAKER_07: well spirit yeah yeah all right i'll go to roma and fix up his
SPEAKER_07: transformation as well hybrid
Jack: do you want me to look at spells again and then
SPEAKER_07: four for roma's aroma yeah yeah sure i mean uh because he's gonna let uh fourth level
UNKNOWN: level four yeah level four same with you baptist you should also probably look into level four
Kakashi: spells
Kakashi: that suit your character maybe
Kakashi: okay
Kakashi: uh let's go
Roma: i already have what's different in this one anyway i'll just copy that
Kakashi: into
Roma: nothing nothing i know of oh yeah it keeps taking away my special skillet because you
Kakashi: have the normal skillet here that's why
UNKNOWN: yeah
Kakashi: uh yeti hide what's this
UNKNOWN: uh resistance
UNKNOWN: tough
UNKNOWN: okay
Jack: it's just cold stuff okay it's just gold or is it it's it's just cool he already has like mostly
UNKNOWN: all of the resistances with this uh barbarian anyway uh okay i'll just copy your token change
UNKNOWN: the stuff around and just like uh change the token and everything yeah image i'll change that oh
UNKNOWN: all right anything else i was just saying we just gotta level them up yeah uh do you want me to
Jack: immediately add the spells to his thing then i would need uh dmgm permission
UNKNOWN: all right don't snoop around
Jack: too much i'll do the same as always and just well yeah
UNKNOWN: uh i'll
UNKNOWN: do oh well i'll tell you to put server next yeah yeah let me know i already changed your
UNKNOWN: permission so yeah uh okay i'll send like a short like what happened in between in downtime actions
Kakashi: and uh maybe we can do like maybe we can pick up the session uh where you guys like plan to go and
Kakashi: go and do something like that
Kakashi: gamble a bit and stuff like that
Kakashi: next time well you know i'll be in that bar yeah uh and
Kakashi: i don't know do we want to do something like the gambling stuff and then
Kakashi: we continue training or do we want to just skip one month and then you guys are just
Kakashi: gambling and then we pick up from there
Jack: you can say it happened in between right
UNKNOWN: on a day off or something yeah we can say that okay all right uh see you guys next week i think
Roma: everyone is good for next week right should be as of right now okay uh bob did say that he has
SPEAKER_00: like exams and stuff but he didn't say that he would be off he keeps saying that he's been saying
Jack: that for weeks
UNKNOWN: uh
SPEAKER_07: I don't know it's rough being a college student man i don't know
UNKNOWN: could be
Kakashi: uh till 18th of may 18th of may holy shit how long this is yeah exams last
Jack: so well apparently until the 18th of may oh my god
Kakashi: uh he said he would only be available to like three hours till 18th of may so we can do like
Kakashi: small sessions uh if you want to do like side missions in between when bob leaves we can also
Jack: try to do that do that or plan that somehow well but will there still be time because it's a two hour
Kakashi: thing yeah i mean if you're fine with doing just three hour stuff then that's fine i'm good either
Jack: way well excuse me i would like your training thing could have happened didn't you go for that
SPEAKER_08: if you're just doing stuff uh what like the training we could do the training
Jack: thing continue the training well go on if all this one uh yeah maybe we can but but the thing is
Kakashi: i'm just gonna skip next week right the whole training part yeah because it doesn't really
UNKNOWN: matter i bobbled here it's true true
Baptiste: yeah one level in broke do you i mean it kind of works
UNKNOWN: with your character that makes sense fuck it yeah is there a way i could change it to dexterity
UNKNOWN: instead of fucking wisdom yeah you do that i think it was just asl anyway right so it's just 16
SPEAKER_07: let's see yours your ac is 16 now so it just rolls it by one yeah
Jack: hey the same as you know but you have double life speed
SPEAKER_07: no no devils but let me go back one level level down and then add a rogue yes okay roll uh
Baptiste: and i was just thinking about i don't know if i'll do it yet okay don't say it like you've decided
Kakashi: okay uh i mean honestly it's up to you guys if you want to do the uh uh training part
UNKNOWN: a bit more we can uh do that i'm good for that uh i mean not today i gotta leave
Kakashi: and i i also don't have a lot of stuff prepared and i have to move around characters and stuff
Kakashi: like that because she's gonna train you for a bit but not like fucking all the time
Kakashi: um she has like stuff to do too
UNKNOWN: um
SPEAKER_08: but for
UNKNOWN: yeah
Baptiste: would it be possible to get an additional power in this training arc
Kakashi: additional power is the hockey thing right that's the whole thing
Jack: the thing that non-devil gets
UNKNOWN: what
Jack: the additional powers other things non-devil producers get
Kakashi: no no yeah that's only non-devil producers and i think jack already picked it
Kakashi: entrepreneurialird
Kakashi: he's doing absolutely the job
Jack: I think that yeah that's a good thing
UNKNOWN: um
UNKNOWN: so uh
Jack: so i'm pretty sure yeah i think even if i don't get things to go by
Jack: and just like we talked before um
Kakashi: um
Kakashi: i guess maybe i should do it
Baptiste: yeah
Kakashi: because
UNKNOWN: yeah
UNKNOWN: you know
Kakashi: i'll give him another option
UNKNOWN: but
Kakashi: it's only for PCs but it's fine
Kakashi: you can choose
Kakashi: he's an NPC but it's fine
Jack: is the devil fruit level up?
UNKNOWN: what?
Jack: do devil fruits level up?
Jack: devil fruits
Kakashi: devil fruits have like
Kakashi: more usage because it's like
Kakashi: devil fruit usage
Kakashi: increases I think
Roma: yeah I was like I can use mine
Roma: four times now
UNKNOWN: so like I could potentially
UNKNOWN: each day
Roma: go yeti four times
UNKNOWN: yeah
UNKNOWN: I think it also counts into
Kakashi: what spell you can use
Kakashi: right so you can only use
Kakashi: with the transformation you can only
Kakashi: use
UNKNOWN: what
Kakashi: two spells three spells
Kakashi: I think transformation is separate
Kakashi: transformations is like
Kakashi: inherent
UNKNOWN: it doesn't improve
Kakashi: it's based on proficiency I think
Jack: the thing improved at level
Jack: five and then it's level ten
UNKNOWN: yeah let me see
SPEAKER_07: devil fruit
UNKNOWN: devil fruit uses
Kakashi: paramecia type
Kakashi: yeah improved usages
Kakashi: level five and level ten
UNKNOWN: what was I just doing?
Baptiste: yeah it's enhanced form
Kakashi: increased duration stuff like that
UNKNOWN: I think for
Baptiste: my feat I
UNKNOWN: go brave
UNKNOWN: brave?
Jack: so brave
Jack: very brave
UNKNOWN: very brave
Jack: very brave to do about this
Kakashi: I think I
Kakashi: do I already have brave here somewhere
Kakashi: well that's not the one piece one but so
Kakashi: it could be different
Kakashi: increase your wisdom charisma score by one
Kakashi: you have advantage on any saving throw against
Kakashi: any reaction friendly creature
Kakashi: the bonus section you can spend
Kakashi: your hit die to gain one number of temporary points
Kakashi: one plus hit die plus your constitution modifier
Kakashi: minus check your state of emergency
Kakashi: one plus hit dies
UNKNOWN: when you reach a probability range
UNKNOWN: no allowing you to love each other
Roma: get out of battle
UNKNOWN: no komplett
Roma: nobody loves the batman
Jack: no way
Kakashi: we'll see we'll see it could be an advantageous area for you or something like that depends
SPEAKER_07: no this is an open field yeah yeah but you know he doesn't hit for that much i don't think
UNKNOWN: let me check also i should probably stop streaming
UNKNOWN: no not thompson not trey uh he hits for a lot not not as much as mirror though
SPEAKER_08: he's got a hit though bro yeah he has got a hit so it's harder now i think i hope
UNKNOWN: hey but at least i have uh evasion
SPEAKER_07: peace
SPEAKER_07: so
SPEAKER_07: you
Jack: you're gonna have to remember to implement the
UNKNOWN: the haki dice right yes i will implement the haki die
Roma: does haki get replaced every long rest or is it every once in a while uh i think it's long rest
UNKNOWN: yeah i think you can even overexert haki like exhaustion rules do apply here right
UNKNOWN: i'll say that the same like spell casting rules probably apply haki so if you
Kakashi: want to use haki but you don't want to use haki you can use haki
Kakashi: don't have haki points you can use one point to get like one level of exhaustion or something
Kakashi: like that okay that's fine with me oh okay okay at least uh you can decide and let me know
Kakashi: and i will you know just as a reminder for myself i'll just write down a few things implement haki
Kakashi: uh brave
Kakashi: brute
Jack: i'm gonna send you a message on monday to hey have you done this yet
Kakashi: implement haki brave brute uh what did he pick something something i wrote it down
SPEAKER_07: no i didn't write it down i already forgot he picked something
UNKNOWN: oh god i just had i just had a thing my passive perception is gonna be 20
SPEAKER_07: oh my god
UNKNOWN: jesus so yes i see
Roma: you know i would hope so you have a goddamn sniper rifle bro oh the axe uh master
Kakashi: yeah that one yes i think that's it right you'll add the spells right i'll do the spell that means
Roma: you're leveling up you're leveling up that means you're leveling up
Jack: my forms with all the spells yeah yeah i'll give you some i'll give you some uh fourth level spells
Jack: that would i think fits i've also done your older spells yeah yeah yeah i'm not worried i just
Roma: because i know the last couple times like i noticed like it was still level four
UNKNOWN: so i was just like all right uh it's fine because like realistically you won't fight anyone as strong
Kakashi: as mira for a while now you won't fight anyone as strong as meera for a while now you won't fight anyone as strong as meera for a while now
UNKNOWN: so it should be good for a bit and we'll what
UNKNOWN: it won't be one-on-one yeah it won't be one-on-one for sure yeah
Kakashi: uh so the fight might be like big points are out of fights
Kakashi: uh we can we can also like not do everyone's
Kakashi: uh
Kakashi: one-on-ones uh if you want me to just like send like uh
Kakashi: you know thing like a passage for everyone's training at the end of the
Kakashi: training thing i can send that and then we can continue with like the normal session
Kakashi: we don't have to do the training part uh like the end of training part next session
Kakashi: unless you want to try out your character and that works better in in that case
Jack: but because for me might be once about half of my well a lot of my stuff doesn't do anything
Jack: yeah i'm better in group combat that's fair
Kakashi: because uh the thing is i was thinking of maybe splitting the party a bit
Kakashi: uh because it would make sense for jack to be not that involved right now with the crew
Kakashi: yeah so jack would just go off on his own and do some training and dip in the bar yeah
Kakashi: uh same with baptiste and the rest of the gang i don't know
Kakashi: maybe baptiste and cade and then i'll split roma and bob and then i can have individual
Kakashi: stories for a bit
Kakashi: we can all be in the same call
Kakashi: uh and i can do like parallel okay because this is like this will be like a big island
Kakashi: uh so it makes sense to split you guys
Jack: uh hmm you don't have to do things you're doing well right if she's gonna be in such a mess
Jack: what if you think it's gonna be too much of a mess
Kakashi: yeah uh i don't know i was also thinking like maybe
Kakashi: after usually like a training arc uh maybe there's like a small
Kakashi: something right at the end of it to make characters feel grown or different
Kakashi: so maybe i'll try to do that or maybe i'll try to do it all together maybe i'll try to
Kakashi: do it separately we'll see in session i'm talking about in session stuff not like
Kakashi: just uh
Kakashi: you know chat you'll figure it out yeah i figured i have a week
Kakashi: you have a week yeah yeah because i don't want to get into like the core uh story stuff right now
Kakashi: uh all right i'll see you guys next week then uh baptist let me know once you finally decide and
Kakashi: we can finalize on that yeah
UNKNOWN: out all right it's already fucking 11 man okay all right uh what are we gonna do when we have
Kakashi: longer sessions again i don't know what i'm gonna do i'm gonna die also i wanted to ask i mean bob
Kakashi: uh it's not here but you guys okay with like moving this maybe bi-weekly
Kakashi: i like my weekly session not bi-weekly sorry two uh session per two weeks i think
Roma: that's what i meant so like four sessions so like saturday and sunday no no no no no no no no you
Kakashi: don't understand me i mean uh every month there's gonna be two sessions that's it
Jack: well every other week yeah
Jack: so we have
Jack: weekly sundays but then once a month another session that's one
UNKNOWN: no i was thinking of doing like one shots maybe i'm not following
Kakashi: okay every other week i'm saying every other week we can do like the main campaign session
Kakashi: and then uh every the week that we don't do the main campaign session we can do a one shot
Kakashi: a one shot of what one shot of anything that we want to do like pokemon whatever like yeah
Kakashi: yeah whatever like the before i was talking but i'm not relying on the other people now i'm just
UNKNOWN: gonna talk in this beautiful channel now doesn't matter to me yes i mean if you guys are not into
UNKNOWN: it that's fine it doesn't give you time to figure out what you want to do yeah because i feel like
Kakashi: i'll have to like add in more things and work on like more stuff um and one chance i don't really
UNKNOWN: have like to put that much effort into so it's going to be normal session random thing normal
UNKNOWN: session random thing yes i guess i mean if you're not into it that's fine we could just do it on
UNKNOWN: the way it's fine if you'd rather do the main uh campaign anyway then that works for me either
Kakashi: i was just like putting it out there because uh after the campaign ends we will have to do
Kakashi: something else maybe so i was trying to figure out what might we gel with in general by doing
SPEAKER_07: a bunch of one shots in the campaign what that's after the campaign yeah that's after the campaign
Kakashi: but no i was talking about if the campaign ends do we just want to do one shots or do we want to
Kakashi: do are you you're saying like let's finish the campaign and then we can try a bunch of one shots
Kakashi: and then figure out what
Kakashi: you
Jack: after the campaign ends then that gives you time to prepare for the next one right if you just do
Kakashi: a random shit in the team while we wait i guess that's true yeah that works either way for me
Jack: well it's fine for me but i'll just
UNKNOWN: what i'm at least gonna run it
Kakashi: hey if anyone else wants to dm by all means man i want to play
Kakashi: play sometime
UNKNOWN: have a look at the
UNKNOWN: for in between what i'll have a look at a pre-made adventure or something
Kakashi: while we are in between uh yeah we can we can do some um what is going on
Kakashi: fandelver or some like well-known campaigns too i've tried one fandelver
Kakashi: campaign honestly it just feels a bit odd to me to do like one shot of one shot of one shot of one shot
Kakashi: like how it was supposed to be in the first frame if something seemed to be off and i do it
Kakashi: the game is starting to get an idea like what we've already built
Jack: let's do the first set the first the
Jack: Suffering Messenger
SPEAKER_08: yeah just 멋있 são as have you
Kakashi: yeah it's like coming out of the case fighting goblins why not you don't have to stick to exactly that we can also do like the same plot but in different settings like different worlds that can be fun i think doing it in like
Kakashi: maybe
UNKNOWN: for me. We can do like
Kakashi: free Ren and then we do just
Kakashi: bring Mines of Andalver into it.
UNKNOWN: Yeah.
Jack: They don't have to explain all our spells.
SPEAKER_00: That is
SPEAKER_00: true. It is a lot
SPEAKER_00: of work to explain everything.
Jack: Well, they'll figure it out. It's still a while
Jack: for the campaign to end.
UNKNOWN: Yeah.
Jack: Or so you think.
UNKNOWN: Right?
Jack: He's gonna kill us all.
UNKNOWN: Oh. Yeah.
Jack: Next week he's gonna be like, well, and that's the end of the campaign.
Kakashi: Yeah. You see that
Kakashi: what happens at the end of the campaign
Kakashi: is you all die and new people
Kakashi: take over and get your revenge
Kakashi: in the next one.
Jack: We're getting kicked for the server.
UNKNOWN: Maybe.
SPEAKER_07: Maybe. You know. You never know.
SPEAKER_07: I should leave.
SPEAKER_07: I'll talk to you guys next week then.
Kakashi: We're just gonna do normal
Kakashi: campaigns. It's fine.
Jack: Unless you need some time, more time to
Jack: prepare something, right? Yeah. In case
Kakashi: I need some time to prepare,
Kakashi: that's fine by me.
Kakashi: Last week I just took the week
Kakashi: off. I didn't work on anything.
Kakashi: I'm just being real with you.
Jack: Can I get a week off just to prepare
Jack: for this?
Kakashi: Nah.
Kakashi: Well,
UNKNOWN: the
Kakashi: week that Roma cancelled, I did
Kakashi: like, prepare for the session
Kakashi: or anything. I was just like, you know,
Kakashi: I have a week off. I'm just not gonna
Kakashi: worry about it. And I still
Kakashi: somehow made, like, every
Kakashi: arc decision that I wanted to make.
Kakashi: So it's fine.
Kakashi: Alright. In case
Kakashi: I need time for
Kakashi: some sessions, which I would
Kakashi: definitely will need time
Kakashi: near the end.
Kakashi: Not now. I think I have, like, this
Kakashi: arc completely figured out.
Kakashi: But when I do, I'll let you know.
UNKNOWN: Yeah.
UNKNOWN: Alright.
Jack: If you don't need to,
Jack: I don't see the point of actually escaping
Jack: to do random stuff.
Kakashi: Yeah, I understand. There's no need
Kakashi: to be doing bi-weekly if I don't
Kakashi: really need that much time anyway.
Jack: Just continue what we're doing, right?
Jack: Yeah, yeah, yeah.
UNKNOWN: Yeah, yeah, yeah.
UNKNOWN: Also,
Kakashi: I think even
Kakashi: if there are, like, one-shots,
Kakashi: we do need some time to figure out.
Kakashi: Like, what the
Kakashi: rule system is, and, like,
Kakashi: fucking book stuff, and, like, all that.
Kakashi: So, I don't think it's worth it anyway.
Kakashi: Alright.
Kakashi: I'll talk to you guys next week. Bye-bye.
UNKNOWN: Peace.
Kakashi: Are you guys working on
Kakashi: something? Because I want to...
Kakashi: I'm gonna shut down the server, too.
Kakashi: It's on my PC.
Jack: I'll just ask you to turn it on sometime next week.
UNKNOWN: Oh, well.
Kakashi: Baptiste, do you want it on?
Baptiste: Uh, no.
UNKNOWN: Oh.
UNKNOWN: Wait, wait.
Roma: Oh, sorry. I just remembered one more thing.
Roma: Sorry.
Roma: I wanted to
Roma: talk about...